Well,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by ting.
If you go to Rogan dot [inaudible] dot com you can save yourself 25 bucks off of
either their cell phone service or one of their bad ass android phones.
The idea behind ting is a company that is essentially trying to conduct business
in an ethical way instead of trying to rip you off.
Instead of trying to charge a ridiculous amount of money,
they charge less.
They try not to rip you off and they can still make money and you can do
business and not feel bad about it.
And that's sort of the idea behind tank.
Provide you great cell phone service on a reputable network.
They're on the sprint network,
so it's not like some rinky dink network that they made themselves.
It's a big national network and it works great.
And they have the best android phones.
You can get.
The Samsung Galaxy s three,
the,
the note,
that big giant fucking thing.
They're amazing.
Um,
it's great service.
It's a,
the idea behind it is there's no contracts.
You cancel whenever you want to.
You could put more than one person on an account.
Like you can have like a little family account and all share minutes.
There's a lot of great things about it.
If you,
if you don't use minutes,
they were,
they make it up to you in the next bill.
It's like,
it's a super cool company.
No one's trying to rip you off.
I've had direct communication with the people behind it and they're just really
nice.
It's cool.
It's a great company and uh,
we're happy to be in involved with them.
If you go to [inaudible] dot [inaudible] dot com you can save yourself 25 bucks.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com it's o,
n,
n.
I,
t.
If you've heard this podcast,
you've heard us talk a million times about all the different supplements and all
the different Shit we sell as far as like strength and fitness and health
products.
But make no mistake about it.
Everything we sell it,
shit that I use is things that I would recommend you try.
And it's things that have shown benefit to me,
uh,
for health and for wellness and for fitness.
And I think that's a really overlooked part of people's lives.
You know,
eat some fucking healthy food.
Take some vitamins,
get a workout in,
and man,
you will feel better.
I know it's hard to do.
It's super hard to just get started.
That's what's really hard.
It's hard to just get your fucking lazy ass up and actually do it,
but you've got to decide to do things.
You've got to write shit down right down that you're going to do it and be
completely dissatisfied with yourself.
If you don't hit every checklist,
hit every point on that thing that you've written down.
You can,
you can get things done in your life.
You can get moving and you'll feel better.
That's what's most important.
If you're healthier,
you're,
you're actually gonna feel better.
Actually.
Gonna feel like a better person.
It's going to work better anyway,
go to [inaudible] dot com use the code name,
Rogan,
and save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right,
you freaks.
Listen,
Melissa Etheridge is here and I don't want to bore the shit out of her with our
stupid commercial.
So it's over.
Brian.
Cue The music.
Make it official.
You
well,
good experience.
[inaudible]
ladies and gentlemen,
Melissa average.
Thank you so much.
Pleasure to be here.
I've got to tell you,
when I got a message saying,
Melissa Etheridge wants to do your podcast.
So I had to think,
did I ever talk shit about me?
I just had,
I had a really cute cause that's
easy.
Well,
everyone's easy.
I'm easy to,
it's,
you know,
it's like you want to,
if you ever did and I didn't ever did make fun of something,
would you like,
look,
I wasn't,
I didn't mean it.
Of course.
I completely understand the common yet I'm actually someone that knows that if
you're making fun of me,
that means that I must be doing something successful.
So I'm all good.
Yeah.
You know?
And even if I'm accusing someone of being pretentious or whatever,
we've all been guilty of being stupid,
you know?
So just a joke.
I have to do it.
I can't,
I can't just let it sit there.
It's in the middle of the world.
And,
uh,
I can't point out
jump does comedy is sacred.
Believe me.
You believe that.
I totally believe that comedy is that part of truth and it's people like you.
It's why you resonate so well with all what you're doing right now is because
you comedy pushes when you stand up in front of people and say this is the
truth.
And then they ha they laugh and laughter is that release,
right?
Beautiful.
I think that release,
whatever that feeling is that when you laugh,
but whatever that thing that makes you laugh.
I think if that was a drug,
if you could buy that like at seven 11,
like you buy a coffee
because when I go to see like uh,
I worked this weekend with a couple of really funny guys with Brian Callen and
Ari Shaffir and,
and Brian Redman here and we worked in um,
uh,
Vegas.
We had the show.
And one of the things I love about like working like a really funny guys,
it's like actually getting to laugh,
actually getting to be an audience member.
Cause like a lot of Brian counts stuff was new.
I hadn't heard it before and I was just how then laugh at,
it's such a good feeling.
It's so,
and you know,
and very similar in a lot of ways to the,
the feeling that a great song can hit you.
Well,
it's what we do.
We do very similar things.
We take human emotion,
human experience,
and organize it in a way that it gets past all the normal barriers.
You know,
I can,
I hopefully can tap into a feeling that a person has that goes beyond their
head,
but they go straight into their heart and,
and then they get to release it because you know those,
those will be,
that'll cause you sickness too if you keep doing emotions inside.
So comedy is the same.
It's all about letting it,
so
the difference with comedy is the,
your stuff gets better the more hear it.
Like if I hear even like the greats,
like Richard Pryor,
I can only listen to like one of his bits,
like once,
not twice in a row,
not three times in a week.
I could take one of your songs and just slap it on,
repeat and enjoy it more.
I've come to your windows,
it's so high.
Just that to scares me now.
Yeah.
That.
I'm very lucky that my,
my art form is more like I get to,
I can
write a song,
I can record it and in that moment I can put it there and they're like,
like,
bring me some water.
There you go.
And then you know what?
20 years later,
oh my gosh,
I get to sing and again and I can put all kinds of new stuff.
I can do whatever I want with it.
And people want to hear it like Yay,
they pay money.
It's just kind of it.
It's like with comedy,
you have to always keep coming up with new shit.
Be Funny.
Be Funny,
dude does it last.
You got to keep the,
you can't like re Redo bits from decades past,
but a great song that comes out,
man,
that's permanently great and better with time.
You know,
it's a weird feeling to be a person who knows nothing about music.
That's,
that's who I am.
I really no zero nothing.
Don't even play any instrument.
Nope.
Can't play anything that when I looked at music written down,
I've never,
never investigated it even for a second.
But I love music.
I love to listen to it.
So I'd look at people like you is almost like,
like what you do is it's like a form of magic or something.
Like the ability to make awesome noise used to be out chemical in that it was,
it was sacred music was because if you look at the nature of the universe and
reality and you break it down into quantum physics,
it is a reality that is based on octaves and dimension.
So if you understand music,
you can understand.
It's one of the reasons why I understand the nature of reality so much that this
is what happened like eight,
nine years ago.
And once you get to understand that we,
that we are all octaves,
we are all instruments,
we're all vibrational beings,
then you understand,
oh,
music.
That's why music will never ever go away.
That's why it resonates so much.
Yeah.
For a lot of people to hear that kind of talk and like,
Oh God dammit,
you just hit my hippie bullshit button.
I know you're a resident.
What do Ya,
what are you,
you're resonating and being great.
What the hell does that mean?
You know what?
And,
and they absolutely,
they lived there.
I,
I have an understanding and a belief and we're all just made up of our beliefs
and I walk with my hippie understanding belief and go on with it.
I think there's,
there's obviously,
uh,
it's,
it's a in a,
a beautiful and imaginative concept,
but there's just sort of clear evidence that there's something there when like
say if you're in your car and like that riff of back in black comes on the radio
and it was just the perfect sound and the perfect time,
you know,
maybe your board of whatever,
you'd be annoyed by something and that that data like your whole body,
like it's just like,
that song is so good,
it fires you up,
you know,
there's certain things that,
there's a certain feeling that it does to your body that if you could just buy
that man,
it'd be very,
very,
very valuable.
Or looking for that,
aren't you?
I think everybody is.
If you could,
I mean,
I'm,
I'm super inspired by music and I think one of the reasons being,
because I don't understand it and because,
um,
I don't play it,
I can't create it.
So when I see someone that can can,
to me,
it's like,
wow,
it's like this totally different thing than what I do.
But I get to see the same sort of energy that makes anyone great at any art.
I love seeing express through different mediums that,
that pure resident,
I mean,
I hate using that word again,
but that,
that residents of expression,
you know,
whatever it comes with that burst and it shows the world,
whatever it is,
whether it's in a song or whether it's in a sculpture,
I love seeing it.
You know,
I love seeing it in all forms.
You can,
uh,
you can go look at this.
He can look at it scientifically and I'm,
I'm just gonna use the word vibrational because we,
if you study scientifically,
not even Hippie wise,
and he'd study quantum physics,
you will understand the vibrational nature of the universe.
And so art gives off a vibration.
Absolutely.
You can break it down.
They,
they have,
they have little machines that can show if someone's looking at a picture and
they have a feeling you have a vibrational energetic change inside of you as a
reaction to that.
Wow,
that's amazing.
They actually just had something the other day I think yesterday where they have
the,
they showed the first thought,
uh,
like where uh,
the brain of a,
I think it was a rat and it,
it they,
they,
because they could see it,
uh,
like visually see a thought.
I'll try to find it.
But it was really bad as it was just,
well,
I know they've been able to figure out how to take an image of what you,
what you can see.
They'd be able to like simple shapes.
I go a simple triangle and simple squares.
They've been able to take images like they've somehow or another that's reading
your mind essentially.
And that's a beginning,
right?
I believe it's the whole experience of all of us understanding that thought
creates in that and that's what all of this is made up.
Yeah.
He's thought that's a weird thing for people to wrap their head around.
And what I always try to say is like,
you know,
everybody looks at the imagination as if almost as if it's not necessary,
but you know what I mean?
He's a childish one with his wild imagination,
you know?
And that that sort of term,
what what people don't understand is that's what created everything.
Everything hard,
everything.
You can touch,
everything you get in and fly everything you drive around in.
That's all coming from imagination.
It started with,
yes,
all of it.
Everything that we've created,
good or bad,
it's coming from an imagination like the idea that we don't put a lot of respect
in in that and that we don't look at that.
It's like being this and that's the real sort of sacred creator of the universe.
Absolutely.
Creation.
And it starts with our own responsibility,
what we create for ourselves every day.
And that's difficult because people want to blame.
They want to say,
oh,
this happened to me because of that person,
because I don't have enough money or I don't have enough love or whatever it is
that blame and it's hard to look at your own creation of what you created
everyday.
We're so malleable,
you know,
and if I think we grow up in the wrong environments,
it's very easy to also raise children in the same environment and repeat this
really fucked up pattern where no one has ever stopped the train and said,
okay,
let's look at the patterns that we operate under and how many of these are
beneficial?
What are we doing?
Like why are we living in the same goddamn way?
And everybody's miserable?
Let's just stop and think this through.
And No,
let's not yell at each other.
I don't want to be yelled at.
You don't want to yell at me and I don't want to yell at you.
Great.
Okay.
We agreed to that.
Will that we told him we won't.
Yeah.
Now let's think things through what?
We know what,
you know,
what the fuck are we doing on this planet?
We're enjoying our company and we can do that or we can just create chaos and
create problems everywhere we go.
If we repeat the same patterns,
which were like to do,
if somehow or another,
it doesn't reset itself.
Exactly.
I actually feel like we're in a big resetting right now.
Like I can feel it.
I can start to see it in the people around me.
And just that there's a way that you can reach anybody who would like to listen
to you can,
you can,
you can do that right now.
That is different that 10 years ago you weren't no available like this.
Yeah.
No.
10 years ago there was nothing like this.
You would have to put it on a radio show.
They would put you in jail to crazy job,
lost it all.
They would tell you,
you're out of your mind for every,
almost everything you're talking about illegal drugs.
But I was listening the other day,
um,
uh,
are,
um,
was reading rather about the Hollywood sign.
You know,
the Hollywood sign used to be Hollywood land.
Yeah.
And at one point in [inaudible] 76 somebody got up there and made it Hollyweed
because they passed some decriminalization law in California close to being
legal nationally during Carter's administration.
Wow.
So close.
So yeah,
it's,
if you really look into the,
the journey of cannabis,
you know,
it's,
it's criminal and it's,
you know,
what they've done to this,
this natural product.
It's ridiculous.
It's really bad.
And the people that are trying to keep it illegal,
or the people who could benefit from it the most,
oh,
he's,
those people all need to get onto it.
That's what I love when,
when Colorado and Denver and Colorado is doing that thing there,
you know,
making it legal,
they're saying,
look,
it's just better than you.
No,
no.
You're not going to get in a fight.
You go to the barn,
you,
you know,
have a smoke,
you're going to be chilled.
You know,
you're not going to cause damage.
Yeah.
You're not going to just become a crazy person who can't even drive.
You know,
that's unbelievable that almost everywhere in America are these spots where you
can get fueled up with a drug that makes your body not work so well.
And we're fine with that car getting your car.
And of course we don't want you to drunk drive and we pray take cabs and we
always say that.
However the possibility is always there.
You're talking about a drug that massively inhibits your thinking process and
makes you do really irrational shit and you're combining it with the access to a
car.
I mean the idea that people see through that our society was built on that.
All
the,
it's that worker society.
Keep them on the caffeine and the sugar and the alcohol.
Oh and do you think it's a self fulfilling sort of a thing?
Cause those things are all awesome.
That's
caffeine is awesome.
Sugars.
Awesome.
The alcoholism,
the shit.
It's all good stuff.
So I mean is it possible that we just like it,
you know,
instead of caffeine changed the world and sugar too.
Yes,
it was what brought industry too,
you know,
Britain and that's why colonialism happen.
That's why they conquered the world so they could bring spice and taste and
sugar.
And in the 18 hundreds of the,
uh,
the British doctors were like,
Whoa,
wait a minute.
We're seeing all these new diseases now because of sugar.
It's,
it's a drug,
it's a drug.
And they were like,
no,
too late.
Once they had figured out how to extract sugar from natural products,
and then you can get these massive doses of it right into your bloodstream,
eat spoons of sugar kids.
Do you see the,
they get a little,
oh,
we got a cupcake at school and they lose their mind.
Yeah.
I gave my little one cotton candy yesterday.
She went off.
She only weighs like 30 pounds.
You're like a pounding.
Say It's,
it's tough.
It's tough.
It's a drug.
And for drug wrecks,
our immune system sugar just totally wrecks our immune system.
And that's why a lot of us are so sick.
Yeah,
it's really close to like a toxin.
I mean,
there's a lot of people that are trying to say it's a car.
So I felt fed my baby a delicious toxin.
But it's fine.
They're so available.
And they do have kids going to want it.
Can't have it every day.
No,
every day you'd healthy.
But if you're at Disneyland,
fuck,
it's time to go off and go.
They sell cotton candy machines at target for the kids.
These little machines,
they're like 50 bucks.
You make your own cotton candy.
That's so wrong.
That's just pure sugar.
And then put them in front of TV and you'd,
you've got,
we've brainwashed him and then it's all good.
Yeah.
And then they're ready to be plugged in,
unfortunately,
but is awesome too.
That's also probably exactly.
I am not a,
I don't,
I'm a not a,
I'm not going to do any of this.
Right.
I believe in all of these things in moderation.
It's all about balance because I don't want to be the other way.
I don't want to be,
I'm not going to do this and this and this and that,
because those things are fun and they're beautiful in the ad tastes and spice to
life.
And I want that balance.
And it's just about balance.
Yeah.
It's a moderation thing,
right?
It's like figuring out how to ride the waves of not be addicted to it,
not victim to it,
but also enjoy a little TV every now and again.
Yes.
Ham,
some good shows off.
I'm like,
what's wrong with you?
It doesn't mean the shutting off the world.
I think that it's not an either or situation.
I think if you know what,
what you're being manipulated by,
when you see like an advertisement of,
you understand the manipulation behind it,
the,
you know what they are intending.
If you know that,
then you can be safe and go in,
but if you go in and just watch mindlessly and more,
you will be swept away in it.
Yeah.
It's like a balance issue,
right?
Yeah.
I think there's just got to figure out how,
how do you do it?
How do I do it?
It's a constant practice every single day.
It started when I went through breast cancer.
It's that sort of,
Oh fuck,
I could die in.
All right.
Oh,
wait a minute.
This,
this is serious.
And I,
I,
I had this,
I actually ate,
it was one of those senior,
you're talking about we,
before we went over,
you're talking about cannabis and actually the difference between smoking in an
eating it.
And I eaten a couple of cookies and they were of course delicious.
I had a bit more than I should.
And I had one of those really severe trips.
And in that came a very clear understanding of the nature of life,
of,
of balance of,
and I came back,
went through breast cancer,
went through the,
the system.
I did the chemo,
you know,
I was on bald and I did all that and I gotta have it and going,
wait a minute,
while I'm in this,
every doctor I had kept saying,
cancer starts when sales go bad.
And I go,
okay,
well why do cells go bad?
And none of them would answer me.
None of them had that answer because that's the way our medical system is set
up.
And this has been a journey of finding out why did my cells go bad?
Why did they go back?
It was the,
it was my nutrition,
it was my stress.
It was,
I didn't drink enough.
Water is very simple stuff and it's about an emotional imbalance.
We got to bring emotion back into balance in the body.
Yeah.
It's,
it's as much of a factor I believe as all the other things in your body,
your blood,
your tissues,
your bone.
I think your,
your emotional health is as important as your,
your biological health,
health of your actual body.
If they're connected.
Yes,
it was.
The um,
unfortunately was the Catholic church in 400 and when day they cart decided that
he,
he was like,
I went to the church and he said I want to study medicine.
I want to study the human body.
And they said,
okay,
you can study.
It wasn't medicine yet.
He invented medicine.
They said okay,
you can study the body but the emotion and soul that stays with the church and
that's one of the reasons why this break happened and all of our great thought
and intention and the smartest of us for hundreds of years have only developed
the body separate from emotion.
And we are now seeing that break down the whole system or whole healthcare,
everything because it,
it,
it's just not true anymore.
Emotion plays I,
my belief is it plays almost all the part of,
of disease dis ease.
Wow.
But what about like little children with horrible disorders?
I should.
Well then you have to get into,
and this is where it gets it.
This is where it talks about.
We are here to create,
this is where we talk about we're here to create.
We are here to work through whatever we've decided.
I mean,
you know,
this gets in a real spiritual stuff.
The stuff before,
you know,
and,
and it all depends on your basic belief.
My belief is all of us have,
all of us create what we need to work through to create and learn what we need
to in this world.
And so I can't look at anyone as a victim.
I can't even a child.
I don't blame them.
I don't say this is your fault.
I say,
you made an agreement in this place to do this and I am sending you all my love.
And I believe in you and I believe that you will,
you can be a miracle
when you,
when you say that like,
but do you mean that like when you see someone who has a disability,
you don't see it as a disability.
You just see that they're just another entity in this life and just go forward
with love and it all works out in the long run.
It all works out great anyway.
Is that what you mean?
What sort of,
and it's what you,
it's what you deem works out in the end because a lot of people have different
ideas of what that is.
I have tons of people that come to me who are stage four cancer and the doctors
have said there's nothing we can do.
You're going to die in a few weeks.
And they,
they come to me all the time in cities all over the world and I want to,
and I try and sometimes it works.
Sometimes their belief is I just give them another way of looking at it.
If you have another perception other than cancer is something that that happens
to me and oops,
I got it.
If you understand it is my body is on this journey and my emotion and you're
willing to to dissect and and break apart.
You know,
what am I eating?
What am I feeling?
What am I doing?
Where am I?
What do I need to change?
You can control cancer because it is a symptom.
It is not something that happens.
It is your own cells that have been so taxed by your [inaudible],
your immune system,
which has been taxed by sugar or motion or any of that stress that is sick
stress.
It's so taxed that then those cells go bad.
Is it all environmental though?
I mean is it all emotional?
It's some Arthur,
some random genetic rolls.
The dice like kids that are born with massive birth defects and along those,
well this is the lie,
this,
it's,
it's how you hold reality and creation.
I believe that this reality is one of thought.
So whatever you are creating,
whatever that know that that massive deformity,
that massive thing,
it comes from it.
It's theirs.
It is theirs too.
I'm not judging it.
I'm loving it.
I'm not seeing them as a victim.
I don't believe something unjust happened to them.
And I don't believe something just happened to them.
I believe that this is the balance of life and we are all here to walk through
it and make our choices.
Wow.
That's heavy duty stuff.
I mean,
um,
I think there's something to a person that has gone through what you've gone
through physically or you get to a real point where you're,
you know,
you're worrying about your body ending,
you worrying about your trip being over.
And I think the insight that people that have been through those situations and
they,
it's,
it's really remarkable and it always makes me wonder why we can't wrap our heads
around that without a crisis.
You know?
That's what,
that's one of the reasons why I love to come talk to you.
It's why I want to talk,
because I would love to just have one person not have to get to crisis,
but to go,
wait a minute.
That might be the path that I'm,
I'm on.
Maybe this can help me.
Maybe it can,
because when I was in it,
I saw what the fear of death can do.
It it,
it holds everyone.
It cancer.
I mean,
I still see people and it's been eight,
nine years now since I was diagnosed and went through all that and people still
look at me like,
are you dying?
You know,
they,
they still hold.
It's a powerful energy.
Yeah.
It's,
it's um,
it's a weird part of our life and weird part of our journey.
The body just sort of failing prematurely in some strange way where it's growing
its own problem.
Well that's,
or there is something,
there is some choice that I'm making.
My body is perfect.
Every single human body is amazing.
Perfect.
Right?
But what about people?
That's what environmental factors,
you know,
exposure to radiation.
Why are you there?
You are there because you,
you major in again is not about blame,
right.
It's this is,
you chose this when,
when you were just an angel or a spirit of what everyone calls you believe they
chose,
chose this life when?
From another dimension.
Yeah.
When you've been there.
I wash,
I wonder.
Yeah,
I have and I haven't,
you know what I'm saying?
It's like,
uh,
the,
the ideas from the psychedelic experience.
Yeah.
The ideas are very intoxicating.
But,
uh,
I wonder how much of it is correct when it comes to things along those lines.
Like you choosing your own destiny,
try letting go of the fear,
try believing it.
Tribal leaving it just once for one day.
Yeah.
I couldn't believe it,
but,
um,
I mean I could discipline leave it to,
you know,
I could do it.
So it can be whatever.
Yeah.
I mean you can,
in that sense,
if you believe something like that,
I really can sort of create a reality for you.
Absolute powering that.
That's the,
and that was my,
I'm going to choose
to walk like this ever.
And it's not easy.
Believe me.
Everything in a real reality you want to say.
Okay.
Well except for that,
cause that just happened to me and I'm just blaming that.
Yeah,
I would,
I would really look at it that way if it wasn't for a massive environmental
issues,
you know,
um,
toxic issues,
things along those lines where people clearly like a whole town gets cancer
because it was a fucking factor in your bar and they're throwing some shit in a
lake and people don't know about it.
Now go beyond that story,
go there and 10 years and find out whose life was made better,
whose life was changed,
what happened.
There's everything happens for a reason.
So you think you like a deterministic,
deterministic person.
What you believe that the world is moves in a way that you cannot control?
No,
no.
Again,
again,
it's,
it's slippery because no,
I don't believe I'm not a fatalist.
I believe each and every one of us controls our own reality every single day
through every choice we make the choice of,
of what?
Eat,
what to think,
how to feel.
A lot of us think we don't have a choice in how to feel.
Well,
you hurt me so I'm angry.
What do you,
I don't have a choice.
You do.
Everything is choice.
And then,
you know,
throw some spirituality on it and you get the,
everything's a choice just between love and fear.
And if you break it down that small into every breath,
it's like a practice.
That's why the monks go live on the hill and all alone so that they can get to
this perfect place of nut.
Neither blame.
You're not a judge and you're not a victim,
you're just right in there.
In the middle.
Yeah.
The monks essentially give up all civilization,
give up life entirely.
No sex,
no.
I would not want to do that at all.
And I believe you can do that in this life as you were referring to earlier.
Balance.
Yeah.
To,
to joy at all.
Yeah.
I've always felt like monks are pussies.
You can't handle it really.
I know relationships are tough but wasn't relationships.
All of the best music comes from relationships.
Hey,
I'm,
I'm living proof.
Yeah,
Moss.
Right.
So go back and listen to like the greatest songs of all time.
It's always a guy and a girl,
like talking about some shit.
We thought we'd be together forever.
Those,
yeah.
I mean,
if it wasn't for that,
where would the other beautiful art come from?
There's a yin and a Yang to this crazy life.
Absolutely.
And when you can hold on to that,
they neither going into all the fear nor all the love.
I'm not all airy fairy.
If you can hold that middle life gets really cool.
Yeah.
If you can hold that metal,
how do you go about holding that metal?
Do you every single day he just,
it's a practice.
It's a practice.
You don't,
you just,
you stay in the,
now did your personality change when this happened?
Uh,
in a way I let go a lot of personality reactions.
I believe that you call up who,
who,
who is going to be,
who's sitting here today across the table at you.
I'm choosing who gets to answer this.
I would like a 51 year old Melissa to answer you.
Not 14 year old,
14 year old has answered,
you know,
in my relationships,
14 year old Melissa,
she comes out and she said some pretty naughty things and that's who I can
choose how to do it.
So it's,
it's this choice every day how I do it.
Yeah.
That's a weird thing where we sort of get stuck in those young patterns.
The patterns are,
I mean,
a lot of people do though.
It's,
it's really,
really common.
Yeah.
Every day I do,
every day,
I'm looking at it right now.
Oh No.
That's how he always does it.
Oh,
you got to,
it's finding out how to manage your life is probably one of the most difficult
things that the person can accomplish in their life or attempt to accomplish,
I should say.
Isn't that what it's all about?
That's,
that's where I want to,
I want to come to you.
I want to come to listeners.
Everyone as a person who I achieve my goal.
I said,
I was born,
I set out,
I was in born in Leavenworth,
Kansas.
I wanted to be a rockstar.
I ought to be rockstar.
I wanted to meet Bruce Springsteen.
I got to meet Bruce based.
And you know,
it's like those dreams came true.
Well,
there's something that happens after those dreams come true.
You realize,
Oh,
I'm still me.
I still have all my problems.
I'm still so where someone who might hold that big dream and think,
well,
I'll never get it.
And so they just hold it out there and then they have lots of excuses.
Well,
if I got that,
then I'd be there,
but I'm not,
you know,
I,
I'd have enough money.
I'd have enough this or that.
Then you can get caught in the,
the turmoil of life and always believed that,
well,
if I was famous or if I had more money,
I'd be better while I'm here to tell you that the fame of the money,
it's nice.
I'll absolutely,
I love not having to wait in line.
You know,
it's right.
Yet it does not solve all my
problems and it can cloud you in a little bit of confusion.
Oh,
we see that every day.
We've all met famous people or seeing people wig out up in certain ways.
We are like,
okay,
you're,
you're being like a child throwing like a child's Tantrum.
Yeah.
Because they're making choices to let the child still do that.
And there's a weird imbalance.
There's a certain type,
there's a one type of celebrity.
The I told you,
so celebrity and the reason why,
I mean,
why,
why call it that?
It's like they're the type that once they get famous,
like they feel like the whole world fucked them up until now.
And now that they've got the world by the balls because they're famous,
they just really act shitty to be evil.
And I've seen that,
that one that's a really shocking one.
And you put that out and what you put out comes back and yeah,
just,
just sit back and watch their,
their world.
Yeah,
come down.
Yeah.
It's hard enough getting through this life without acting like the world owes
you something.
And that's that sort of delusional thinking among successful famous people.
It's very,
very odd
because that's like the furthest from the vulnerability of the reality of our
biological life.
Right.
But it was the dream that we were fed.
I grew up in the 60s and the 70s you want to be,
you want to do better than your parents did.
You want to make more money and buy thanks.
Because that's the meaning of life.
That's how you show your successful.
Yeah.
Not Management.
Not like health,
not no happiness,
smile.
Oh No.
All those things.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
Yes.
Miles per hour is probably very important.
I never thought of it like that,
but that phrase,
smiles per hour,
like you should probably have a lot of that.
A lot of smiles per hour.
You'd probably get off way better in life.
A fence.
So huge like laughter and having fun,
so God damn huge.
People that don't laugh about things,
I just don't understand.
Yeah.
There's this is emotional stunting sort of a thing to that,
right?
Yeah.
How do you fix that?
You again,
take care of yourself.
You have to,
you can fix yourself.
You cannot fix anyone else.
That's funny how people who can't fix themselves.
Oh yeah.
There's a lot of those.
There's a whole lot of that and married to view those.
Those people are crazy.
They'll tell you what to do and you're like,
look,
your own life,
bitch,
you're
not happy and you're giving advice.
Once I realized I cannot fix anybody else,
no one else.
Right.
I became much happier person myself.
You can't fix them,
but you can rock their world with a song that changes the way they feel about
life and if even if only like for a three or four minute song,
even if it's only for the three or four minutes,
but the positive reaction that someone can get for something like that,
is that going to affect their choices?
Absolutely.
Then you start seeing how it,
yeah.
If it like w w when you had jobs.
If I don't,
do you ever have jobs like regular jobs back in the day,
back in the day,
had a couple,
if you listened to a bad ass song before you went in for an audition or for an
interview,
like you'd be in a better way,
Maria,
you,
you'd have a little pep to you and they'd be like,
I like this average girl.
She's got Muxy energy.
Yeah,
because you had heard some,
you know,
some fucking Badass music in your car on the way over there.
It's vibrational.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but that's hippy shit that balanced the hippie.
Bring your inner hippie out.
But the regular hippies are so annoying.
They've ruined it for the hippie.
Ideal about Doty lazy motherfuckers.
You guys,
ew,
stinky,
lazy hippies.
They have ruined the hippie culture,
but not a bounce of Petrolia and not even a little bit of petroleum you don't
like,
but truly at all.
But if you met the most wonderful woman,
she smell,
smell it virtually Pachulia would give you would I could get into rosewater
right?
I can't do it.
Rose water is nice.
It's this smelly Hippie is a problem.
It's cause the smelly humans a problem.
Ridiculous.
Silly Bitch.
What are you covering up?
Why are you putting rocks under your armpits?
Get some deodorants.
Aluminum Hammer is a natural deodorants like herbs and shit.
But don't put the aluminum.
Not Aluminum is bad.
It's really bad yet.
Chlorhydrate and why were they putting it in?
Why are they putting in Deodorant?
Because the aluminum
industry 100 years ago,
when it first started,
had a lot of waste that they needed to get rid of.
Wow.
So this aluminum waste became sodium fluoride.
Which was put in our water and um,
it was thought to use.
Oh,
it'll keep us from sweating,
which I'm sorry.
You're supposed to sweat.
There's a reason.
Oh,
so it's only antiperspirant,
not deodorant.
Right.
I don't mind sweating.
I just want to smell nice smell.
Nice smelling lady.
He smells very nice girls.
If there's any,
thank you very much.
Um,
but stinky people,
you should know your stinky,
stinky hippies.
You fucking lazy.
Bitches.
Get up,
get up,
go run water.
Water is everywhere and soap is not expensive.
Okay.
Go get craft and you can use defense soap.
It's natural.
Okay.
So it's a great soap that has like tea tree oil in it and eucalyptus oil.
It's all natural.
It's good.
It's good for the skin.
Keeps good.
It keeps you from getting like ringworm and stuff like that.
Are you talking to someone specifically?
Yeah,
unfortunately.
Grapplers anyone who practices Jujitsu has to deal with ringworm whirl.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's really,
really common as well.
Staff,
you can get staph infections too.
I've had ringworm a couple of times.
I've had staff twice.
Jeez.
Yeah.
Once I caught it really early.
So I didn't have to get about x.
It took like a
topical,
but once it got pretty bad,
it was weird.
I had to take these super strong antibiotics like careful cause that if you look
at people's,
I believe my cancer started with,
I took these super duper antibiotics.
It's actually the stuff,
accutane.
I had really bad acne because I was out of balance in the beginning and then I
took a whole bunch of like the super duper antibiotics.
Those also are killing everything good inside of you still don't understand
that.
Right?
Or people have,
when you do rounds and rounds of antibiotics,
you are really knocking yourself down.
If you have a diagnosis of cancer.
Look in your past,
was there a time,
did you do the antibiotics right for it right before it,
because it compromises the immune system.
But you have a big infection like a staff.
Absolutely.
Kind of have to do kind of.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So now it's a matter that you do have to get the antibiotics great for.
Then you have to put probiotics back in here.
So hoadly and you have to really be aware of your acid and alkaline balance
inside of you because that's what keeps your immune system so a lot of green
leafy vegetables and fruits that acid off the list.
Things along those lines.
No gluten,
no sugar.
Yeah.
That gluten free.
Where the hell was that 10 years ago when I was there any gluten free food 20
years ago?
Was there any?
No,
hardly any.
Well,
because in the last 20 years what has genetically modified our wheat and it's
become just this an edible food.
The real problem with that is that Lasagna is delicious and you gave some,
there are some good I can.
I can bring you a gluten free Lasagna.
I can do it.
I'm going to,
I had some Sunday for Superbowl.
I did.
Don't make me go.
Joey d is how you guys see paltry gluten.
What are you talking about people?
Gluten free.
Lasagna just seems like a mess.
I don't want,
I don't want no part of that.
I don't want to be pretending that I'm enjoying it.
I'm going to bring you some pot.
I'm just going to bring you some pos.
Isn't it a balanced I like,
I like regular pasta though.
Unfortunately.
I've tried eight Ezekiel Pasta and I use it because it's healthy for you.
A sprouted grain posts.
No one.
It is,
but again,
the taste,
it's like,
Ooh,
wow.
You can find the balance.
There are,
they're spelt,
spelt is like a lesser wheat.
It's still a wheat and it still will fluff up.
You can get spelt bread.
That's it's pretty good.
I don't believe you.
I'm going to show up him and bring up pretty good.
I'm like,
why would I do that?
What?
I can get awesome delicious bread.
I can make a sandwich.
I like fat Italian bread.
Oh,
be yummy.
Yummy.
I just feel like if you love it,
yes.
If you're getting other people,
I don't need it.
A lot doesn't.
Yeah.
Good.
I'm pretty bad.
It's absolutely,
but I like when it's there.
I love it.
Yeah.
Linguine with clams.
You have that like real and Queenie.
Not some funky with Holy Pasta Shit.
How was the whole week still bad,
right?
Is that always?
Yeah,
you too hardcore for a whole week.
I know.
Can just start selling t shirts too hardcore for a whole week.
So you're,
you're like USB,
like super organic thing.
You see again,
it's balanced.
You would,
you would think,
but you know what?
I have kids and they would run me.
I have teenagers.
They look at me like really going to serve this for dinner.
So it's about finding that in between,
you know what?
I searched and searched and I did find good gluten free pasta that my kids don't
even know that it's gluten free.
Oh now they do.
Oh yeah.
Cause they're listening to your podcast.
They're going to be in trouble if they know.
I thought this is real spaghetti,
right?
Hippy bullshit.
Yeah.
So I do try to,
it's about a balance.
It's about doing it seven,
at least 70% alkaline or that the whole foods and 30% you know what?
Yeah,
I had a pizza Sunday.
It was super bowl football.
We'll have a pizza.
Pizza's delicious.
You have a diet.
It doesn't include PC or something wrong with you.
That's,
that's dumb.
You have one day a week,
one day a week,
absolutely.
Dab Salumi.
Do you know,
um,
a lot of athletes,
they,
they eat clean everyday of the week except one day and they'll have one day
where they go bananas because it helps you because otherwise you don't go,
you know,
start,
oh I need,
I need this.
I'll never have this again in my life.
And then you're up in the middle of the night.
I haven't done that.
So you know,
who has amazing cheat days?
I just started following him on Twitter,
the Rock,
if you ever ever seen with that guy,
ain't dude pull up some photos of what this guy eats his cheat days or as it
were.
He's a massive,
massive human being and he works out like two or three times a day.
Two it's crazy.
Like he's very inspirational of a year in the exercise.
If you go to his tweets like the guys up at three 30 in the morning and doing
cardio because he's got to be on a movie set.
It's six.
Yeah,
he's nuts.
He's super,
super,
super dedicated,
but he eats like really clean and healthy and it takes pictures of his food.
And then on one day a week he goes off and I'm talking like giant stacks of
brownies and like,
uh,
like a gallon of milk.
That dude had like a mug.
No.
Yeah.
Look,
look at his,
uh,
his cheat days.
It goes pink.
Look at those pancakes.
Look at,
he's got four giant pizzas.
It dude goes off.
Look at the brownies and that Mug of milk,
that is fucking insane.
Fucking shredded.
It guy's got no body fat.
It's because all throughout the rest of the week he goes bananas.
He's at the gym all day,
practically does movies and hits the gym.
I do it backwards.
Yeah,
you do it.
Yeah.
I don't even do it backwards,
bitch.
There's not a moment in your life you live as much intensity is that guy.
Not,
not even when you eat shit for
doing it,
but doing it that way.
He's,
he's just must be like a,
a battery,
just like constantly going like
this shirt and people that like,
you got to go wow.
Like what's good,
what gets you going like this?
Three 30 in the morning,
you're doing fucking cardio.
I had six o'clock time where had to be at work.
I would get up at five 58 put my shoes on and show up.
I'm not going to get up at three 30 and do cardio.
Indeed.
I've never done anything.
It's intense is that
he works so much though.
Maybe it doesn't have like relationships so he has to do something.
So like working out you only thing cause he works in like nonstop.
He's on a movie set for like seven months and then to the next movie to say,
yeah,
well everything I've read about him,
um,
everything,
every interview,
every like tweety does.
He seems like really thankful for all the good things that have happened to him.
And he works like if he's got this attitude work hard to get their work harder
to stay there.
So that's what I think it is.
I think he's just obsessed with gratitude.
Gratitude.
Amazing.
Gratitude
is a medicine.
You can change your life with gratitude.
You really can write him.
And we,
and as we were saying before about people who've had sort of near death
experiences and became like very spiritual afterwards and really sort of
understood life in a,
in a,
in a broader perspective like that you are choosing to,
to look at life that way.
It's kind of difficult for people to visualize without the,
the real life changing experience.
But if you could,
you would see so many amazing things about life.
It's the whole thing is a,
a beautiful mystery.
Yes.
The whole,
to hold it with less fear than you have a less fearful life and realize that
that energy that you're expressing unfair,
you could be expressing on positive things and advancing your position in life.
Think your dancing.
Yeah.
Advancing you the way you interact with people and enhancing your relationships
and advancing the way you approach whatever you do for a living and enhancing
your creativity.
Think of how you think about your boss or someone that you work with,
the energy that you spend going,
oh,
they're such a bad,
remember that next time that thought pops in your head go,
okay,
okay.
I know.
I don't feel that way,
but I am grateful for that job because blah,
blah blah,
or just I'm grateful.
If you can find something to be grateful about your boss,
that's even better because then you can kill that fear and turn it into love and
I know it's all hippy dippy,
but that's what creates more of that positive vibration in your life.
You know?
You could also do,
and this is very practical,
if you have someone in your life that you don't like and you have to work with
them,
use them as an exercise,
an exercise in your own patients,
an exercise in your own ability to actually be kind to someone that is not being
kind to you because it gets really weird when you do that.
When you're kind to someone and they're not being kind to you,
they like,
they get even more aggressive sometimes and they,
they're almost like they're stuck in there,
they can't swim.
It's like it becomes this weird sort of situation.
Fear and pain is is an energy that people want to hook into you to release.
Yeah.
There's actually,
again,
you can look at it energetically that I've got this little going on.
Oh,
there's somebody,
oh,
I can be,
I can give it to you.
And if you react,
if you re act what I gave you,
then,
Oh,
you've got it now.
I don't have it anymore.
I'm good.
So break that chain,
don't react,
respond,
look at them and go,
okay,
where can I find gratitude and love here?
All right,
I'm just going to,
you know what?
You've got a lovely tie and just move on.
Yeah.
For some people though,
they're always at like a seven or an eight on a scale of one to 10 with being
upset at things cause they,
they're sort of this,
this almost momentum of chaos in their life from jobs to relationship to this,
to that they,
they never have this moment where they can just
stop.
Well,
here's one.
When you start practicing living your life intentionally understanding that it
is all vibrational,
then you start understanding that the people that come into your life are all
part of your vibration.
So if there's someone in your life who is always on to seven and eight and
bringing it and losing it and all that,
that's part of you and the only thing you can do,
you can't change them,
but you can go inside yourself and go,
okay,
where's the part of me that's afraid of that?
I'm over the top and then I'm losing it and then I end and you go in and heal
that and then that person will disappear or they will change,
and I've done this for eight years now and I can say that that is exactly what
happens.
How do you explain stalkers?
I don't have any.
You don't have any,
but other people do because it's a sphere.
You manifest it as a fear.
It is.
You are afraid that as as sexual as you're being in a photograph or in a movie
or something,
that someone's going to take that and that's going to end,
take it wrong and come back and hurt you.
It's a fear
that's,
that becomes very hippy dippy when you're dealing with the reality of actual
people actually being victimized.
Just depends on what your definition of reality is.
Wow.
You're really putting yourself out there and I know I can only do it here.
It's,
it's such a weird way of looking at the world and a lot of people think that
that strange,
although nonjudgmental,
very non judgemental way of,
of looking at the world,
it's almost akin to like the secret
like that kind of thinking.
The secret is like the Mcdonald's of this movement.
I would say I feel that a lot of people are starting to understand this on a,
on a very basic level.
Like,
okay,
if I just eat better,
I'm going to feel better.
Okay.
Food must have some sort of energy that makes me feel,
and you start with that and then you realize the things that do make you feel
better,
make your day better.
And,
and it,
it's,
again,
it's not going to happen all in one day,
but it is something that is happening on a very wide scale and the,
it is the tipping point right now.
I think there's more people who,
I think there's people at home going home.
That's what I always thought,
but I was just too afraid to say yes,
I have a model of the world.
I think that comes from more from the media,
from books and movies and TV shows.
That's sort of our model of how life goes because we see that almost more than
we see our neighbors lives.
We see that almost more than,
you know,
we see other people interact with each other and you think about how many hours
people in from the television watching on television shows and it's almost,
it becomes this very strange thing where fiction becomes almost the framework
for the culture and it also,
it's sort of like,
it becomes a strange issue where everyone has to wonder,
where's the,
what are the roots of all this coming from?
Where,
where's the roots of all this crazy behavior?
Or are we creating this ourselves?
Is it,
is our media creating this world that we can't live up to that we can't keep up
with and we don't?
The unnatural
interactions with each other always perfect endings.
The people that you're following through the whole movie never die.
Like,
what are you showing me here,
man?
What are you showing me that's so influential?
And it's they're showing it to themselves,
as we said about the people who were in the movies themselves.
It gets so crazy and delusional,
like they are obviously caught up in whatever the fuck that is as well.
Yes.
And there's a lot of,
you can,
there's a lot of different
roads of thought and you can,
I've,
I've been down the,
you know,
the David Eick,
I've read all that I've gotten.
What do you think of that guy?
What's interesting is I started reading him f eight years ago and I read all
this stuff.
You read all of it.
I know.
Can you believe that I,
I was realizing I needed to understand if I was going to change my life and I
wanted to live too.
I wanted to understand,
to really understand this on a very like a molecular level.
I want to get this.
So I started him and the beautiful thing was,
is he,
he deconstructed everything,
but doesn't he also believe in the Reptilians?
Yes.
Okay.
Part of this part of it.
Yes,
indeed.
Part of this whole thing is each of us is entitled to our belief and that's what
his belief is.
And that's what his belief is,
that they're all reptiles though.
But it doesn't mean he liked,
he's like lectures on this.
Oh yeah.
But he also goes past it.
He also goes past it and he starts talking about,
but in the end I understand that I am living an intentional reality and that I
create my reality and I have to go into an only take care of myself because the
enemy and he even goes hippy dippy and he gets to love.
He does at read his last book.
Well,
I believe that a lot of people that have wacky ideas also can have very good
ideas.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think the idea that you can,
I mean that's what,
that's the idea of taking someone's oh good work and connecting it to some bad
work as if it negates the good work.
It doesn't really,
I look at the world again in balance and you can't have all good and the the,
the issue comes when you start labeling and judging what's bad and what is evil
and then that's a whole nother homeboy does think that the ruling elites are
lizard people.
That is an issue.
That's an issue with thinking.
That's an issue where you got to,
you know what he will present you with.
Probably won't I Betty.
Whoa.
I wouldn't that.
Wouldn't you love to get David I to sit down with Neil degrasse Tyson.
I'll have him tell him why there are not reptiles running this world.
He would,
it would it be hilarious and fascinating,
but that's how that's is.
That is a fucking crazy belief that there's all kinds of ways to look at it.
I believe in bigfoot.
Okay.
Not a hundred percent you can break it down.
You can say the reptilian ancestors of ours are actually this,
the whole darker side,
the whole,
we've got our it scientifically or Reptilian brain.
That's part of us.
That's the part of us that if we can imagine these horrible things that,
that they have done,
each of us has that inside of us.
We're actually way worse than reptiles because roadhouses kill things and eat
them.
They don't torture them and time to trucks and pull them apart from each other
and do all sorts of shit that you could find everyday on the Internet.
Yeah,
the reptiles onto that,
so to call us reptilian and a lot of ways we are way cooler than reptiles.
First off,
we're capable of amazing shit the reptiles can't even fuck with.
But if you get past that,
I mean w reptiles are actually less cruel than us cause reptiles don't kill for
fun.
They kill the EU,
you know what I mean?
That's the,
they're there just to try to get by in life and their,
their program to not be emotional and think about things.
But if your program to be emotional and think about things and you still don't
to act that way,
that's way worse than being a reptile and then horrible things are going to
happen to you.
I still hate reptiles.
I do not like them.
They're not my friends.
I don't trust anything that you can't train even a little.
He never fucking train a crocodile monitor.
You know?
You just keep feeding it until it's,
you know,
to stuff so it doesn't want to bite you.
And they get used to handling them,
but they never your buddy,
they don't care if you fell down right in front of them.
They just start eating you right then don't give a fuck a monitor lizard.
I believe some.
Okay.
Some of the reptilians are humans.
Oh,
they came back.
You think?
So tell species sort of a reincarnation you to the wind in the willows.
What are you doing about it?
So cute.
When you're talking about making the choice,
like in another dimension,
like a psychedelic dimension,
making the choice to to resist in this life and that you create your reality.
Do you,
do you think that that people can be other animals?
Do you think that a life form is just a life form of humans?
The only one with a soul?
What do you think you want to know to know?
I think that this,
I think that this earth is a place of biological life and that it is a special
place that,
that um,
all the other dimensional spirits can come and work through Karma.
It's one of the only thing places where you can get through Karma.
That's why I don't blame anybody for anything that is quote unquote wrong with
them.
So you think this is like a waystation?
Yeah,
I think this is,
yeah,
this is a waystation station where you learn,
I think this is a life school.
This is a school.
Yeah.
Wow.
There you go.
That's fascinating.
Um,
it's,
what's really fascinating also is how different people come to it at different
levels that come to it from different starting points economically and
physically and geographically.
It's all about what,
what you need to ascend.
We are all ascending and last.
You're stuck in Africa.
And when those shitty towns,
it doesn't even have water now or they're so close to,
or they so close to nature,
they,
that's the cradle of civilization.
They,
they've existed for of years.
Yeah.
But they get eaten by lions.
It's true.
That's not,
that's not,
I'm not saying it's good or right.
I'm saying there's always a different way to look at everything I guess.
I guess every day that you don't get eaten by lions,
just you saying,
there you go.
Yeah.
And you get that gratitude,
but then they eat like fly hamburgers.
You ever seen that?
Have you seen that?
See I choose not to.
It's the craziest thing ever.
The,
the d like mosquitoes,
mosquitoes,
they make like a cheeseburger with mosquitoes and they take them and they use a
pan and the mosquitoes are so thick around them that they take these pants,
like it's a giant like cooking pot and they throw it through the air and as
they're like swinging it through the air,
it's killing these mosquitoes because they're hitting the back metal and they
keep doing this over and over again.
It's sticks to the bottom and they scrape it up and then they fry it and make
like a sad face off and all the flies fallen to the mosquitoes.
I know,
I guess.
I guess that's better than getting eaten by a lion,
but I dunno.
No,
it's yet,
none of us can understand what that person is even going through.
When you look at all the poverty and all the terrible places on earth and the
war and all the strife and all the thing,
and then you look at the good aspects of life and you know,
and when people were cool to each other and kind,
and when you look at this,
this big balance,
you know,
what do you,
what do you see?
Do you see like a work in progress?
I see like a gym.
I see a beautiful
creation that works so perfectly.
This whole reality is like a super mega bio computer that is so brilliantly
engineered that we can't even see it,
that we don't even know we're in it.
We come here and we forget about it and when I look at the bad and the good,
I'm,
I'm grateful for the whole experience.
I'm grateful for everything this is,
I'm learning,
I'm growing,
I'm creating.
That's all I can't do.
I can't feel their pain for them.
I can't take their pain away.
They,
they are here to work through that and make their choices.
The,
the,
the issue also comes down to a sort of educating more people to the idea that
the reality that you choose to accept the way your,
your reality is in front of you at this very moment.
What,
what you can write on paper and take pictures of that.
That is your life.
It's not,
this is just where you are right now.
Yeah.
This is what you're doing right now.
We are only aware of 4% of the whole energetic spectrum of,
of energy that that may,
again,
I'm talking physics,
only 4% of it can we see there's 96% of a whole energetic world that we are
unaware of.
So it's kind of silly that,
I mean,
and this is again,
science that we think that that 4% is everything.
Okay?
Yeah.
Well this still has,
how many isn't there?
Like a massive of the university
they believe is dark matter.
And they don't even know exactly what that is.
Because what's happening is I think in the next 10 years,
our own scientist,
and it's already begun,
they're starting to say,
okay,
we are seeing that our universe is constantly expanding.
You've heard that,
right?
The constant expanding.
Well that expansion is the creation is us creating an intending.
That's the nature of our universe.
And as above,
so below.
So are we constantly expanding.
We are this great,
huge Mandela where this,
uh,
um,
I forget what owl there goes my brain.
See I smoke too much saying
no,
it's this.
Um,
it's the thing that Hologram,
that's it.
And,
and when you understand a Hologram,
a piece of a hologram contains the whole thing.
And that's how we are as human beings.
We are in this hologram and each of us have a hologram was like a fractal.
Yes.
Is a fractal.
Really?
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
And we are,
and when you understand Hologram and what it is,
you'll understand that we live in a holographic universe.
So the only way somebody wrote a book,
Holographic Universe,
I started reading it,
but I don't know what happened.
Kids,
they can be,
it can,
it's a big,
you know,
piece of steak to digest.
The idea though is becoming more and more mainstream that the reality that we
see in front of us might not be the entire picture.
That's let's just start there.
Let's start start there.
Yeah.
But the issue comes when,
when people get all either incredulous or hippy dippy,
you know either or.
You have to stay in the middle of,
that's what's gonna save us is that people in the middle.
That's why I've said button like gays,
I was out in the straights and gays,
but it's the bisexuals that are going to save us because they're going to go,
you know what?
I just want to choice.
Or they're just greedy or agree.
Yes.
Did the double your numbers are my numbers.
I don't know.
Have you paid any attention to these recent ideas of a computer simulation
theory that the earth is some or the universe itself as a simulation?
Well,
it depends on how you look at it.
I do.
When you see,
when you as I have just just studied the fractal,
that nature,
the,
the nature of the universe,
the quantum physics,
it's the perfection is astounding.
And then you start to think,
well,
we as a,
as a human race are just trying to replicate what we see.
And so we've made computers and we are like,
okay,
this brain can't think that fast,
but I can get this computer to think that fast and all of a sudden these
computers are starting to look like reality.
Wait a minute,
maybe our reality is,
and then you,
you walk away with,
okay,
it's just intelligent design and I,
you know,
I'm not going to get outside of the game right now so I might as well play the
game and I might as well,
I understand the rules now.
The what,
what,
whatever the design is.
It seems pretty clear that there's
no question about it.
There's some sort of a progression going on and this is a progression going on
with human consciousness,
with human innovation.
But there also is a progression going on constantly,
and the universe,
new galaxies are for me.
Oh,
he knew new stars are forming.
It's,
it's very,
very,
very strange because to think that somehow or another,
it's all just happening.
Oh,
why?
What's going on?
What's causing it to happen?
Is it just,
it just is okay.
But even it just is unbelievably fascinating.
Yes.
It just,
is it good?
Don't you don't have to call it God,
but it just is the force behind hyper Novas the force behind black holes and the
idea of fractal universes.
It's the force behind the idea that inside every galaxy,
a supermassive black hole with one half of 1% of the mass of the galaxy and
inside that galaxy may very well be a whole nother universe with hundreds of
billions of black holes and hundreds of billions of galaxies around them.
Yes.
And each one of them,
another universe,
and it's,
and you can go the other way and go inside your body.
Yeah.
You can look at yourselves and you can find exactly the same wonderment when
they get to that string theory shit.
And they start talking about everything being strings that are vibrating and
it's all in how much hair there is.
Even in live oak tree,
this is all space.
Yeah.
That space is the 96%.
The 4% is what our,
our,
our in our brains hold together in front of us so we can have this experience
and create the idea that a rock is all space.
That's what it is.
Good.
Put it under a microscope.
Yeah.
You'll,
you'll see it immediately.
Yeah.
If you go deep,
deep,
you see that most of it is just,
what is this?
Just the way it vibrates.
This crazy shit.
That's just the way it's vibrating.
I never thought I was never a school.
I was always just music,
you know,
hanging out,
whatever.
When I started actually reading about quantum physics,
Ken,
Ken Wilber,
really great.
He's,
he's,
you know,
based in science.
Yeah.
Bill Lipton,
they're all,
they're based in science and they're saying,
look,
this is the wonderment we found and we think it means more.
There's a gentleman who recently did an interview with Neil degrasse Tyson who,
um,
I should give them credit so people could look this up.
It's,
it's the most ridiculous thing I've ever heard in my life.
Coming from a scientist when his lid,
he essentially said was that in the inner workings of quantum physics,
when they get to these bad ass crazy equations,
one of the things they found is self correcting computer code and this self
correct and computer code was a type of code that was invented they thought in
the 1940s.
And uh,
it's,
they,
they found this very code in the theories bond and the,
the calculations of quantum physics.
I don't know what the fuck,
well,
it sounds like,
yeah.
Clearly
we are discovering ourselves and we're discovering the great code,
the gigantic,
you know,
computer that is this beautiful earth and is us.
Yeah,
I guess,
but it just seems like even putting a label on it.
Yeah.
It's one of the things that I've always felt like,
um,
is the gentleman's name is James Gates and he's the one who discovered this
computer code.
So it's she just go check it out and read it online cause it's so crazy.
You wrap your head around this doubly even self dual linear binary error
correcting block code first invented in the 1940s has been discovered.
I mean it literally is like the Matrix if this guy's right.
Yes.
It literally is like the Matrix.
Yes,
come on.
Yeah.
Well the idea is that if they were able to create a simulation that it would be
indiscernible from reality and that what we might've already done this,
we might have already transgressed from the biological life into this symbiotic
sort of computer life.
We just don't,
we don't,
we don't recognize it yet.
I think a lot of it is when you realize that you are creating what's in front of
you,
then you can get out of that game.
That's fucking ridiculous.
Try it I guess,
but the problem is does it only work?
It looks like that's what how I felt about the secret.
I'm like they're only interviewing winners.
I don't lose her.
Sort of tried the secret.
There was like a young lady who's a very nice person.
She's a friend of,
um,
the flux,
her name Bro,
Kelly,
Kirsten friendly,
Kelly Kirsten.
She used to always come down to the comedy store and a,
she was a super positive and she,
I remember she came down,
she's telling us about the secret,
you know,
she just started doing the secret,
living a lie by the secret and everything's amazing now and I can see how I'm
going to totally manufacturer a completely new life.
And,
um,
then I met them.
I didn't see her again for about two years.
And then,
uh,
I met them again at another comedy club and I'm like,
it,
she was all bummed out and I go,
uh,
I go,
how you been?
What's going on?
You still do the end of that secret thing?
And she goes,
yeah,
I really wanted to see if this makes sense to anyone else because I've been
doing everything they said and my life is a fucking wreck.
And she's like,
and I have all these people in my life,
I can't get rid of them and I can't get them to straighten their life out.
And I'm always dragged into this bad relationship over and over and over again
and job socks,
work socks.
I'm like,
wow,
absolutely be in the secret to,
yeah,
you need to like let people know you can't just think things and all of sudden
the world.
That's why I call the secret to Mcdonald's.
You can,
it's,
it's a process.
It's,
it's the idea,
which is great.
I love that they got the idea in there.
It takes practice because it is belief.
If you look at your life and you believe,
oh,
I don't have enough and I want this,
you are coming from lack.
So you are creating lack.
It's a,
it's a crazy,
uh,
formula and how you think it's very hippy dippy.
People must get upset.
That kind of thinking.
Do you ever have,
I don't come them around me to know.
Well,
what they would go after is they would go after the idea of children with a
terrible diseases is their choice.
That's what they would go after.
After that is where it breaks down because people don't,
people want to hold on to the thought that it is possible for something.
Just to happen to you
with no reason.
So do you believe that this life leads into another one?
And you,
you do this life the best you can and then reap the bounty in the next life.
My belief now,
now,
cause that's,
that's my belief is this is a school,
like I said,
and that we are all ascending and there are those who've gone before us who have
figured it out and overcame death,
which is pretty intense.
That's a lot of work.
Um,
there are those who understand that death is a transition and they are done here
with,
okay,
I've learned every day I'm ready to move on.
And there are those who choose death game over because you know what,
I can't quite figure it out and I'm gonna try it again.
Let me,
let me do it again.
Yeah.
The,
um,
the transitionary phase for a lot of people was made easier by psychedelics.
Larry Hagman,
uh,
was doing an interview on CNN.
It was,
so,
it's really fascinating to see him talk about it.
And he was talking about how when he did acid,
it released him from fear of death.
Yeah,
poorly released it.
So like knowing that and knowing that he died recently,
it was like,
it was comforting knowing that that guy had that experience and had this
different perception,
which really mellowed him out and made them kinder and gentler and sort of he
saw saw it for what it really is.
It's supposedly really is.
I mean,
maybe he's just dead.
I don't know.
That's what a lot of people would like you to thank.
His body is dead.
His spear,
all spirits totally live on.
I mean,
that's just silly to not think that,
but why would you choose?
Why would you choose to believe that this is it and when the lights go out,
that's it.
And it's over forever.
Never.
Why would you choose to believe that it's not though?
Because why would you choose to believe that?
When I go to sleep train,
when you take a nap,
you assume you're going to wake up,
but you're not afraid to just shut off.
Right?
Right.
Why be afraid anyway?
Why be afraid to just shut off.
It don't have to live forever.
You can just shut off too.
That's what I really know.
When you,
when you overcome the fear of death,
you really free yourself up.
Well,
you've got to realize that it's gonna suck.
Okay,
are we going to die screaming and a you buy is going to fail,
but then the next things happen.
Well,
if you're in a plane crash,
did you manifest?
You manifest that?
You think so?
Absolutely.
Whoa.
I know.
Again,
not blame.
Okay.
Not blame mamasans since one asshole in the plane that manifests.
No,
no.
What if he's the shoe bomber?
If there's a shoe bomber on your plane,
did you manifest that?
Yes.
Wow.
You really sure of this.
You accessed Joe.
My belief,
I do believe and then I have to let go and go and I've,
I believe that I do not need that lesson.
I do not need to die.
It terrifyingly in a plane crash.
I do not need that.
Right.
I,
so I'm not even gonna think about that.
That is not even a possibility.
When I born in an airplane,
I actually think this is because I fly a lot.
And for the first few years it was I was a white knuckle.
You know,
every little thing was like,
oh,
I'm going down,
you know,
rock stars,
airplanes.
It's like,
right.
So I,
um,
when I board an airplane now I think,
look at all these lucky people because there is no way this plane's going to do
anything because that's not what I signed up for.
That is,
that's not the end of the lifetime movie.
It's not,
well that is a,
a very positive way of looking at life.
And if you're a correct,
it's going to be amazing.
Yes.
I hope you around to match the face.
Isn't it funny though,
because even if your life was a masterpiece,
people like she got lucky.
And that's belief.
If you choose to always believe that,
see,
look at my life,
it's bad.
It will be bad.
The real problem with that is the people who,
what will people believe all sorts of silly things.
And when I say to that is yes,
but the real issue is have we shown that beliefs can change reality?
Yes,
we can through the placebo method.
That's the real,
that's scientifically measured effect where they've shown that they can give you
something that is not physically active.
It's an inert substance and the idea of taking it for whatever reason,
you believe that this sugar pill,
which is actually poison,
right,
right.
Um,
there's doing something is changing your life.
That's why I tell people when they come to me with cancer,
I said,
what do you believe?
Do you believe that this chemotherapy is going to help you?
Do you believe that?
Then go with your belief.
What about r Kelly?
Cause he believes he can fly.
Well then there's that,
but then he does a lot of other shit.
That's really rude.
So fly.
Yeah.
If our Kelly could just stop peeing on people,
maybe old just saying doesn't do that anymore.
You just saying don't judge because out of that space are you in R Kelly fan?
You stick up for our musicians,
is it?
No,
no,
no.
I think people make their own reality in the world.
You're aware of our Kelly?
I am aware of him,
yeah.
Have you ever watched any of his music videos?
Oh,
I know.
I just watched Chappelle where they always,
this is unintentional comedy.
It's amongst the greatest things the world has ever known for real.
There's a video called real talk and you must watch it.
I will preferably under medicated conditions.
Then the ridiculousness of comes blaring
at you like an awesome parody,
but it's not a parody.
It's,
I don't think,
I mean he might be like parenting alone,
try and be a little bit funny,
but a lot of it's just,
he's bananas.
Like the Budweiser commercial yesterday.
Did you see the Clydesdale?
Did you watch the Super Bowl?
No.
Slept through the whole,
Oh Jeez.
I'm a football fanatic.
It's a really high holy day.
A lesbian.
That's hilarious.
Do a lot of lesbians get into like guide Type Shit like that?
Yes.
My best friends are guys because I can really,
women are crazy.
No,
it's fun.
It's about the balance and,
and I,
I grew up,
my father was a huge football fan and just adored my father and he,
he passed away when I was 30 but he was,
he just,
he was a football coach and basketball coach.
So I just,
you know,
I love that.
And I grew up in the Midwest and it was a big part of my life.
Cause your team,
Kansas.
Oh,
can you image the Kansas City chiefs?
We are in dead last this year.
We have first round pick next to you.
Maybe you chose that.
See,
everything's a metaphor.
Life is a metaphor.
Watching me now I'm going to choose the best is the Patriots case.
You can't drive manufacturing a great team in Kansas.
It isn't.
The money can see unfortunately,
oh that there's gratitude.
There's,
there's will,
I'm telling you,
Eh,
this giant black super athletes are seven feet tall now they run a million miles
an hour.
You got to go to find them when they're 10 they watch them the whole way,
give them the right food.
There's this guys to this day that are recruiting kids and then when they go out
and get high school kids,
they,
they find these white dudes that can shoot a penny that you throw in the air
with a rock and the other good football like a,
like a piston.
They find these kids and all these find these uh,
these uh,
running backs that have ungodly speed and they just keep a good eye on them and
follow them through college and so much money in football.
They'd be crazy not to.
The athletes that are being born today,
look at the quarterbacks,
the new,
they're changing the game that the,
just the technology and training athletes and the athletes are realizations now
of what's possible with various strength and conditioning programs and diet.
Stanford just came out with some glove.
This is really crazy.
It's a glove,
a cooling glove that's better than steroids.
Okay.
It's,
it's legal.
Completely legal.
Somehow or another,
they put your body in this glove and the glove is,
it freezes somehow or another.
Your body,
it cools you down and it cools you down in a way that lets you recuperate at an
incredibly rapid pace.
Ooh,
it's complete new thing they figured out.
So people are going to be able to take this.
They get a little workout unbelievably hard.
Where this cooling glove and through no illegal methods,
no unnatural drugs,
just cooling their body.
They're gonna recuperate like crazy
when they start working with the body's amazing properties to create a better
body.
That's when it's going to work.
Yeah.
This is like a hijack.
They found like a fuck up with the system though.
It was cool that body temperature down and that's a thing they'd been doing with
ice pass as well.
That's something that you know,
didn't really exist that long ago,
but now they're after training.
A lot of guys do these crazy ice baths.
Oh my God.
It's hard.
It's so hard to like relax in there.
You know?
That's the hard part.
Once you climb in your,
your body constricts,
it can't get any air.
You're like,
Ooh,
it's socks.
But if you could do it,
it's awesome for your recovery.
Well,
this is even better apparently.
It's crazy.
So like the athletes that you're,
they're getting now,
they're going to be even bigger.
They're going to be even faster and they're going to be on the Kansas City
chiefs.
You think so?
We got the first pick the first,
even our second round pick is huge.
It's a way up there.
How does that work with who gets to pick?
The worst team gets the first pink.
Really?
That's hilarious.
That sucks for the best guy.
The worst he gets true.
But then again,
let's look,
Andrew Luck and the colts were the worst team last year that got Andrew Luck.
They,
you know,
made to the playoffs.
It's not amazing.
That one super athlete dude,
one was as a quarterback,
one,
you know,
super athlete and one way one Herschel Walker type dude who just unheard of
athletes.
They just can change your whole fucking game.
Huh?
That's because he believes it and then the other people around it starts
spreading it and they start.
So Dude's was slow twitch muscles can they believe they can win and sprinting
competitions against Usain Bolt?
You ask any professional athlete,
what is it?
They'll say the difference between,
you know,
the,
the Ravens and the 40 niners last night.
The Ravens believed it.
You can see when the 49 or stopped believing it.
That's just what,
it's a thick Newton.
Maybe that's just what you believe.
And you've created this whole Superbowl and we are just,
participants are my funny Joe Rogan background.
I'm your new toy that you just picked up today.
I go talk to him.
He just created us in our old world.
Didn't even exist before you came around,
but in your world that is the case.
The reality is,
and your universe,
I didn't exist in a physical form until you till we meet each other.
And you didn't either.
I saw you on TV,
I've heard your songs.
But as a physical human being,
you didn't exist in my world until today.
So it really did kind of event you.
Yes.
And you invented me.
And I'm glad I did that.
So we're all living in invented universes and they all parallel coexist with
each other.
So take charge of your life,
do it.
Get your shit together.
Coaches,
Melissa Etheridge just dropped some pseudo science
but wonderfully empowering suicides.
Right?
That uh,
that attitude is one that's espoused by some of the happiest people.
I know that you create your own reality.
I don't know.
I try to be,
and I get accused of not being really open minded,
but I really do try to be as much as possible.
I
try to,
especially since doing this podcast,
I try to look at every point of every aspect of things and really try and not
really make opinions on a lot of shit.
Just go,
I don't know enough.
I know.
I really can't say and I,
I don't like getting into those conversations with people with the claim.
They do know enough to refute thing.
I think people enjoy refuting things as well.
Yeah.
Very.
It's,
it's all,
if I just look at everyone with belief,
I you are free to believe what you believe.
It's wonderful.
Have you always been an artist?
Have you always been?
Uh,
yeah.
I can't do anything else
anywhere else.
Yeah.
When,
uh,
when did you,
what did you start with?
Because you always be talk eight years old.
My,
well,
I just the transistor radio,
it was the 70s and sixties and I was,
you know,
listening to the Beatles and my sister was a little older and she had a lot of
music.
My father bought her a guitar and I was eight years old going,
please,
I want to play it.
They said,
no,
you're too young.
It'll hurt your fingers.
I'm like,
please,
please.
And then the teacher's like,
well,
let her come.
She,
she won't come back because it's too hard.
Then of course I played in,
my fingers bled and I was like,
I want to do it.
And I kept doing it.
Wow.
See,
I never had a desire to do it,
but I was always fascinated by,
it just was never pulled me towards like a career.
But I was,
when I was a little kid I was probably like seven and my sister was six and we
had a little record player play like 45 hours and we had only a couple of
records and one of them was the things we do for love.
You know that song?
I remember that.
Yeah.
The things we do for love,
the rain and the snow and I was amazed because it was really the only time I'd
ever have access I'd ever have access to music that I could start and stop.
I could just decide,
ready,
go and then it starts and I was like,
now I can really pay attention to it as opposed to like walking into a store and
music is playing or going into a restaurant and music is playing.
This was my first experience where I actually could turn on the music and turn
off the music and realize,
oh,
this is crazy.
This is coming out of this fucking desk.
What is going on here?
Someone's figured out it made him make this flat black plastic disk and then I
put this needle,
he thing on it,
it spins around and it plays me crazy song tones.
The vibration you can start,
you can do the science right there.
That's vibration on the vinyl and the diamond in the diamonds are like rocks and
courts.
That's why all the courts crazy stuff that picks up a vibration and you hear it,
which is just vibrations on your ear.
I think it's one of the reasons why I became a standup comedian.
Yeah.
Because listening to that,
I started asking questions and I remember,
I really remember this from being seven years old that no one had any answers to
why they or how they could put that music on a record.
No one around me.
I was seven years old.
I asked my mom,
she didn't have any fucking idea.
That's my dad.
No idea.
No one had any idea yet.
There were records all over the place.
I was like,
damn,
this is weird.
Like why would you guys ask how they make this?
Like,
guess this freaky to you that there's some thing around you.
Are you curious?
And I was amazed how many people
just actually,
you weren't curious.
And uh,
that sort of started me along that path of looking at all these adults with a
slanted.
I look like
I don't touch it.
You don't know everything might be crazy.
Yeah.
You don't even know how records are made.
His living your whole life.
Meanwhile,
I'm 45 I don't know how records are breaking up.
Go Fuck,
but back then,
yes,
when I was a kid I thought these people were ridiculous,
but if my kid asked me,
I would at least research it.
I'll go,
well,
let's find out.
You know,
I want to know,
you can go on youtube and you can see how easily you could know instantaneous
information.
It's,
that's,
that is changing our world,
isn't it?
Um,
do you embrace it?
Are you,
you're on Twitter,
right?
You,
I see you actually respond to people on Twitter.
You actually,
someone does.
Yes.
Do it.
It's not me.
No,
no.
It's a fake.
You don't do any blogs or anything like that,
right?
You can't win.
You just can't win.
Oh,
you can't,
we missed it.
I missed the whole time and I don't have time to do that.
I have very,
I have four children.
Right.
And I,
I choose not to spend the time,
do I?
I will.
I have a fan club.
I have a whole group of people that that work for me that do that,
so I stay in that arena,
but I know I can't.
But do people think that it's you because you have a verified account?
I always tell them there's not me.
Oh,
it's definitely my people.
I can make,
yeah,
I can make a statement.
I will go to my Twitter and I will go to my website and I would go this and you
can count on that.
If it says Melissa Eppich says this,
that you can count that.
That's what it is.
That I did say it.
Yeah.
See,
the only problem that I would say is that on your Twitter,
when you go there,
it looks like your responding to things to spine,
to people because someone is doing it through your verified Twitter and they're
not saying,
hey,
this isn't Melissa.
Ah,
yeah.
Like a lot of responding.
Britney spears and stuff like that did the same thing,
but when every time they actually do it,
they didn't know who gives you.
They do like dash B a s you know,
like meaning like it's her.
Yeah.
There's a little hill,
right?
Like teams,
someone or another doing this.
Oh,
I think I'll have to go to my team and say,
Hey,
which I've found on,
let's do that.
Really unsuccessful comedians page.
And I was very offended by it.
I was like,
what'd you got a team for?
Bitch?
You ain't got no team.
You can't respond on your Twitter is the actual people for a comedian Twitter,
it's like super important.
Oh yeah.
We'll let you can keep your mean keep sharp.
Yeah.
It's fun.
It's fun to write like little things on hundred 40 characters,
but it's also important to be able to keep in contact with people like that.
You don't do anything like that?
No.
It's too much.
I just don't just don't want to spend the time to do it.
I just don't.
It just not,
it's not in my wheel,
but yeah.
I don't want people to know that much about me.
They know way too much anyway.
Isn't it weird that they just want to find so much about Dan [inaudible]
interesting.
I am.
So it's not even that.
It's not,
it's just they fixate and just decide.
I don't want to look at themselves.
Yeah.
W what was your part of it?
What was your a Woodstock performance like?
That was one of my favorite shows,
four 90.
Uh,
and I just,
that was one of my favorites of Woodstock was a,
what was that like being in that situation?
It was crazy one,
cause it was the 25th anniversary and they hadn't got back together to do this.
And,
and I remember being all they,
we took a,
uh,
a car to a bus that drove to,
the secret Ho how,
somewhere that then put us on a boat that took us up a river,
that to a van that took us to the backstage.
It was crazy.
And,
and I remember Joe Cocker opening the,
the day that,
that I've played and I was on stage and you know,
get by with little help from my friends.
I was like,
oh,
this is awesome.
And it was really,
really wonderful.
They put me in between Henry Rollins and nine inch nails.
That's crazy.
And it rained during Henry Rollins.
So my,
my show,
the sun came out as beautiful.
You manifested that?
I'm at the first rounds fucked up.
You got all negative [inaudible] I know you're not going to blame them.
That's why I'm here to blame.
And I liked him.
I liked him.
Oh yeah.
I like a lot of boy that guy is so I got to play and the audience was great.
There was a bit of marsh and going on in front of me that kind of scared me if
people like,
oh look at that.
Yeah it was great.
My last song I've played like the way do,
yeah there's the mud people.
They started because it had just rained and I could see this patch of,
of gray,
Brown way far.
I mean I couldn't see the end of the,
the audience.
And so I'm looking at all of a sudden that patch kind of turns into a snake and
they all start coming toward the stage and everyone's like moving out of the
way.
Cause it's all these completely muddy people from head to toe.
It was Brian show that.
So that again,
that's a real first world problem.
A bunch of,
yeah.
People muddy or mud because white people are so silly and their decisions to get
muddy.
Yes.
That was black people like fucking concerts.
Cancel pitch.
Oh,
I'm outta here.
I could've called Marsha if it was all black girls.
How many black girls you think it would be there?
The hair,
hair,
fucking high heels and stepping in the mud pinch and shows over.
It takes dopey white people to be slamming into each other.
That's us.
Yeah.
White people will get muddy.
They get crazy and that the whole matching thing,
the mosh pit thing is so bananas.
Like when did that start?
How did to just enjoying the music or dancing.
Why slamming into each other?
You crazy asshole.
One guy jumped up on my stage and go to dive off and everyone just moved and he
just went slam oh flow.
I'm like,
oh dude.
Yeah,
that must have been bad.
Get knocked unconscious.
She kind of just walked off really?
Cause you got thrown out.
If you do that,
oh he must have been fucked.
Signing off a stage and everybody scatters.
Why don't you think that they would catch you,
that you need hurt catching somebody you know?
Oh,
why would you just risk that alcohol that Si si gets you all Brian.
It was also his choice.
It was choice and see a Dick Wad the universe trying to end them.
University setting up bad signals.
Jump,
dummy.
We're tired of your bullshit.
No,
never.
Never.
No judgment whatsoever from you.
What do you,
how do you feel though when you see like a horrible tragedy like Connecticut
shootings?
Yes.
That is definitely the hardest,
and I'm not telling you it's,
it's easy that I just go,
oh,
you know,
that's near the balance.
I understand that through this horrific act that the outpouring of goodwill,
the outpouring of weight,
but we have to do something.
Not only,
you know,
I mean I'm not going to get the gun control thing.
I think it's beyond that to the people,
the person,
a person that can be in so much pain that they can walk in and do that.
That's,
that's a lot of pain.
Let's look at what leads are human beings of our society to that sort of pain
without anyone noticing.
Right.
But wouldn't you have to say that he,
he asked for that wouldn't,
I mean with your field philosophy,
he created this idea.
Yes.
I imagine his pain was so great that the only way to unload it was to spray that
much pain around [inaudible] and the pain,
it becomes all encompassing.
And of course,
you know,
you just fall into it and of course you just going to end your own life.
It's like game over.
It's like tilt or how do you factor in like psychosis and things along those
lines of real mental issues,
real mental issues.
It depends on how you look at what,
just because something is not the way you and I perceive.
Okay,
this is sane and that's crazy.
Right?
Real mental issues.
Where's the line drawn me the line where your thoughts become psychosis.
Right.
And where is it?
The resume spectrum?
Is it broad?
Yeah.
It's just the,
it's just,
it's been vibrating that much more.
And so you are so far out of it that we call it psychosis,
but there are some people that do not have an emotional connection to other
people.
They don't feel remorse indeed.
That,
that you look at that and go,
what,
what is their intention here?
What is there?
What do they need to draw?
I mean,
who knows what they are intending and creating given that it's like,
okay,
you're gonna go back into this,
the biosphere called Earth,
you're going to go in there and we're going to this,
this is your handicap.
You can't feel a thing because it now now work through that.
How do you work through that?
How do you have any feelings?
I mean the idea of not having any feelings and lashing out is a big difference
between the idea of just not having any feelings without the need for inflicting
pain on other people.
That's,
it seems to be a dual issue.
It seems to be an issue of not being able to feel it
for,
of them,
you know,
and also the anger.
And the,
the meat,
the want and the desire to hurt
the belief that if they don't hurt something,
they're going to hurt more.
It seems like with this way of thinking that if you,
uh,
if you,
if you got more people to sort of a look at it that way and more people to do,
do you think that that would be like an empowering thing?
Yeah,
it's,
it's the,
it's the point in which you see that piece is okay,
I need to,
okay,
you might've thrown the last rock,
you might have shot the last bullet,
but I need to be willing to go,
oh,
okay.
I'm not going to shoot back.
I'm going to start a different reaction.
So if you get enough people who believe that
and believe that if I take care of myself that nothing bad is gonna happen to me
that I don't,
that I can't handle because I'm not saying the world is all good a,
it's about understanding your balance and what you asked for and walking through
it.
If I can hold that and not blame anybody else and nobody else is going to blame
me,
then we start walking.
We start moving to a future.
That is all of a sudden you don't need prisons.
All of a sudden you don't need,
uh,
all of a sudden the way we govern ourselves completely changes.
You got to catch people in a very,
very,
very early age and sort of manifest this type of behavior.
You have to get them when they're young,
expose them to nothing but love and curiosity and curiosity with joy.
Why did they think you're crazy?
Call that Voodoo dog.
Cause it is different.
That's what I said.
Like,
oh mom stopped at Voodoo stuff but they will believe it when it called Buddha.
Yeah,
they do that.
Moody's Dough.
How long have you been talking to Buddha?
Oh,
it's been about eight years now.
Eight years.
Yeah.
But I can constantly go,
okay,
you saw that choice you made.
This is the result of that choice.
This is not anybody else.
It's not anybody's doing anything to you.
So there is no randomness.
You think so people that are in like the tower,
when the plane hits,
they,
they made a choice somehow in the world to be in that spot.
If you can look at it without blame,
right?
If you can look at the day that that was what they signed up for,
they wanted to be in it for that long.
I'm,
you know,
I can't tell this to someone who lost their loved one.
They're going to,
that's not going to sound yet.
My belief is founded on that.
I can't blame anybody else for anything,
but it's also founded on the idea that you're creating this sort of reality that
you exist in and that everybody's creating their own reality.
So
if I work,
if I make my little Hologram,
my little fractal of the Hologram,
if I work in making that the best I can,
it's fill it with as much love and as little fear as possible.
Then I helped whole picture because the whole picture has me in it.
I look at it as a,
uh,
I don't,
I don't have an opinion one way or another,
but I do look at it often that it's a combination of that and scientific
reality.
Like I think that if the super volcano goes,
we're all fucked no matter what you believe.
I do believe that.
But I do believe that there's also a real possibility that your thoughts are
creating a good portion of your reality and your thoughts interacting with other
people are actually responsible for culture in the first place.
And that's how decisions get made.
Conversations have taken place,
letters get written,
books get written.
That's how it all happens.
It happens through your mind,
interacting with other people and literally changing things in a very physical
form that everybody agrees on.
But I think that even besides that,
I think there's other issues going on.
I think it's a lot more ethereal than we give them credit for.
It's very strange.
I'm just trying to walk every day,
just walk.
Asteroids will fuck your world up.
And that shit is real,
real.
His ice cream,
they come down and that's a wrap sign and there's nothing he could do about it.
And there's a lot of them out there.
I think that too.
I think you create your reality,
but I also think that there's some random shit that I didn't sign up for.
If it was up to me,
there would be no asteroids.
Okay.
I would work that out.
I'd figure it out.
I'd be like that.
It's gotta be one fucked up way to go with is a big light in the sky for three
days until finally,
boom.
Yeah.
I'm not really into that.
That was not my idea.
I'm pretty sure,
but I could be wrong.
Maybe I was a real mess.
Thinking about it though.
Yes.
Well,
I guess,
I mean if your correct than I do live in this world that's really nutty and
asteroids are there to keep you honest
or you could say,
I'm really grateful that I did that.
They were no asteroids that it was a perfectly uneventful day.
What other kind of crazy out there ideas do you have in your head?
Do you believe in alien contact?
Do you believe in anything like that?
Um,
I don't,
I don't think that there's like a whole race of people.
They're like,
Ooh,
you know,
I'm from another planet,
blah,
blah.
I do believe in multidimensional reality and I believe that there are other
spiritual beings that live on that exist.
I wouldn't say limb that exist on different planes and that,
that is where my spirit goes to when this,
uh,
biological body dies.
I've tried pretend they're watching me all the time.
They lose me.
I'm steady.
It keeps me on the straight now.
Yeah.
But no,
I'm not.
Uh,
you know,
you can,
you can.
I think everything's metaphor.
So I lost a lot of interest in aliens once I had a psychedelic experience.
Yes.
The first DMT trip,
I had a really checked out the whole alien culture and was like,
you guys are missing the hole.
That's also what I,
it's like,
it's not out there.
It's in
and tried to explain that to someone that if you have a Ufo landed on the White
House law,
just the White House lawn got out,
aliens got out and met the president,
gave him some new supercomputer.
It would be way less crazy than TMT.
Like NT is infinitely crazy than that.
And it's you.
It pushes you to see what are you believing?
Yeah.
What's beyond this thing that you are so dead certain is reality.
The deer head just fell over.
That's his reality.
Right?
That's powerful stuff.
Yeah,
no kidding.
He got so excited.
You a pounded on wood.
You're going nutty.
There we go.
Dude.
Your bladder must be huge.
I'm in sitting here talking to you and go,
go,
go.
There's the restaurant.
Don't worry about it.
I can take it.
My cohost and the UFC has a real problem.
That's not the bathroom.
The next to that door to the right.
Uh,
well,
this athlete,
just because fuck yeah,
I didn't think she was going to be so crazy hippie.
She's super crazy happy,
right?
Yeah.
Neil degrasse Tyson would be having fucking,
he would be flipping out,
you know,
it'd be really flipping out.
Cara,
Santa Maria.
That pitch would be going crazy right now.
That's like nine scientific crazy talk.
Vegas was a lot of fun this weekend for everything better except for the pink on
my pillow part.
Yeah.
Brian got so drunk.
I left him at a certain point in the night.
Oh,
after the show I went and played pool because this guy Stevie more was in town,
who's like this world theme is professional pool player and he wanted to play
with me for,
for me that's like,
you know,
it's like a golfer who gets a chance to go play with Jack Nicklaus.
How bad did he kick your ass?
Oh,
he tortured me.
Did you win any games?
Yeah,
I won a couple games.
Yeah.
I mean he messes every now and again,
but he's amazing.
So I did that and uh,
Brian went out and got fucking bull last it to the point where he almost died
and he went back home to his,
I learned,
I'm learning more new things by the way.
Somebody like,
I have this alert thing on Google.
If anyone you know uses red band,
it goes,
hey,
you're,
you're being talked about on this message board.
It's not going to,
no,
it's,
it's just kind of a way to like kind of track things.
Well,
somebody was like,
hey,
just met red band in the elevator.
He,
he came back to our room and we smoked weed.
I went to [inaudible] room and smoked weed in Vegas.
Like a stranger or somebody just made that up?
No,
I,
I slightly remember it.
Really?
Yeah.
And then,
then I guess I went back to my room and I had to go to the bathroom so bad that
I woke up and peed on my pillow and then put a blanket on my pillow,
then slept back on it and then woke up in the morning.
Why
is my pillow when you know Jesus,
Oh,
I'm back.
Sorry.
Timing
for a recap of Brian's weekend.
Yeah,
we have Ari Shaffir coming less tomorrow.
Who I watched scream and yell at the TSA agents.
Oh no Dee.
Did he do it again on doing it?
He's doing it constantly.
That's what he does now.
He yells at the Tsa,
you want to take off his shoes?
I'll take off my shoes.
He goes through a,
a a screening thing and he's like,
he goes,
we're all corrupt.
It's a stupid tomorrow we'll talk about it.
It was amazing.
I got a picture of it.
I,
I tweeted the picture when it went down.
I put it on my Instagram,
but uh,
it was,
it was hilarious.
I'm like,
why are you creating all this problems?
He's like,
this is stupid.
It's corruption.
We didn't ask for this.
I go,
yeah,
but I have to do is just take your shoes off and walk through that little thing.
Show me a chunk and then you go,
yeah,
no,
everyone's going to be fine.
It does naked scanners.
What are you afraid of man?
For Real?
Oh,
I don't go through just for the radiation.
Some of them,
the,
uh,
the new ones,
when you stand up and you hold your hand up like that,
it's not radiation.
Some sort of a radio wave,
you know,
you don't,
you're not in,
I just stay out of it.
Just general in general.
This is more of an issue with the radiation of space actually scientifically.
That is,
if we believe what the numbers are that they say that those things,
those scanners give off,
but they say those are real risk of radiation.
Just actually flying,
just flying,
just being up in the air that high.
It's very a lot of radiation,
you know,
there's a lot of stuff week again can be afraid of.
I just,
I just believe I'm going to do the best I can.
I'm going to stay in the best possible shape I can be in.
Well that argument,
you know,
that way of looking at things is what I've always argued was a good aspect of
religion with religion.
Yeah.
Putting things in the faith of God and having this belief that it's all going to
work out even though it's sort of like,
in my opinion,
I,
I believe,
you know,
people always say,
are you an atheist or an agnostic?
I believe people are full of shit first and foremost.
And that's always an issue whenever I hear a story.
So I look at every religion as a collection of stories.
Every religion has either a collection of stories or collection of rules that
came down from those collections stories.
Everybody's stories are bullshit.
Okay?
So let's just put that out there.
Now I also believe that you believing in those stories and you believing in
God's love and you believing in doing God's will and you believing and being a
good God fearing person in the same way that I believe it's,
you know,
I pretend that the interdimensional beings are watching me,
so it keeps me on the straight.
Now I think there's a,
there's a benefit to that.
There's a benefit to them.
I don't think it's a correct way of approaching it rationally because I think
whatever merit is in the ancient texts,
whether it was actually the word of God,
it very well could be the huge issue is reading it at face value,
using it for uh,
like a framework for how you behave and act in this life when it's written
thousands of years ago by people with very limited access to information and all
of it is ridiculous.
It's all ridiculous.
And the desire to do good is a natural human state.
And to Eh,
to it with fear
is,
is
unfortunate when,
when religious religion and that's right and yeah,
and you're not control when someone has power.
It's really simple.
It's just the same.
It's very similar to what we were talking about with actors losing their mind
when the beginning of my famous,
yeah,
it's almost similar.
It's like they,
they have crazy outfits on and they control the Vatican and so they are used to
everyone being terrified of them and freaking out and they're present works.
So they think they deserve it.
Like,
if I could get the pope on a podcast and the pope's book English,
it would be the most hilarious conversation ever.
He would never do it.
He would leave.
The moment we started talking about pedophilia,
he would probably run out right.
But the,
the idea that this guy is so completely sheltered and so completely revered
where he's just a guy with a wacky outfit on and that is it.
That really is it.
And this idol worship that was actually talked about in the Bible,
you know,
while worshiping false idols dangerous.
Yeah,
it really is.
It's confusing.
It's ridiculous.
And the Real God,
whatever,
stop saying the word or say it if you like the universe or the creator and the
intelligent being whatever it,
you know,
Alex Gray is the visionary artists,
brilliant,
brilliant man and a beautiful human being.
And he came into the podcast and he was just amazing,
but he uses that word God all the time and he's like,
we have to take that word back.
He's like,
stop connecting.
Everyone's connecting it to religion.
And you know,
what did it represents?
The idea of the perfection that it is possible,
represents love,
it represents,
and the his really beautiful a point of view on it.
It really opened me up to that.
I don't use it that often because people misinterpret it and people
automatically cookie cutter,
they shove it into that,
that framework of predetermined patterns of behavior that have been adopted from
religions.
But I think that the heart of everything good at the heart of all good feelings
is that love thing,
that,
that the thing that pulls us all together,
the things just makes it,
it makes us interact.
Well,
that's something,
if you take the teachings of Jesus,
of Mohammed,
of a Buddha,
of all the great Martin Luther Gandhi
of all,
they are all based in the love each other.
Love your neighbor as yourself.
Right?
And,
and that's,
that's,
that's what I'm saying is it,
you can't blame anybody.
And then the it then love the Lord your God or whatever,
you know,
with all your might and your heart and it in.
So it's about infusing love and if you can walk with those really,
I mean,
and,
and to completely taken away from religion because I certainly,
you know,
being the big homosexual I am,
it's,
you know,
I,
I didn't fit into religion at all,
so it's yet,
God,
let's leave.
I believe in that.
I,
I'm with you on taking that back.
I think that was a huge mistake in keeping homosexuals in the church.
What a dumb move because by doing that,
by alienating that aspect of the population,
you,
you missed out on a whole bunch of other people you can control stupid.
Yeah.
Now they're all against it.
You dummy dress better.
Yeah.
There was just shitting chess move,
you know,
they should have embraced the gay people said that.
That's just another aspect of life.
It's just the same,
just as beautiful as a male woman relationship.
Right along with you do whatever you want to do.
And then people have been like,
oh,
there's lesbians in our church today.
And no one would have cared.
It would have been fine.
You had had more people in your church,
stupid,
but you blew it.
Why alienated gay people too.
That to me is,
that's a weird one.
I've never understood that one.
Fear.
Yeah.
Fear of what?
If you hear them actually being homosexual,
your own fear of sex.
Sex depends on how,
where you grew up.
If you grew up in your parents,
if when you were three years old and running around without a diaper on,
if you were touching your genitalia,
I just said,
genitalia,
that's fine.
If you're touching yourself and your mother goes,
don't do that.
That starts your whole waiting when there's something wrong with that.
I'm not supposed to do that,
and that grows and then depends on all their other parts of your experience and
any things that naturally happen to us when they put that fear on it,
then that'll nessie.
How it's not a,
not a coincidence
that the most suppressive aspect of our accepted culture is Catholic priests.
I mean,
they're not allowed to have sex.
That,
and then they're always involved in scandals there.
Sexual,
I mean,
we are sexual beings.
Part of connection with the,
the God.
Yeah.
Well,
how do you explain those dumb monks that are up there?
They're not having sex with anybody either.
They got a good thing though.
These,
they're monitoring their mind to a point where they're controlling their
physicality,
but I still think that shit's ridiculous.
It's true.
I do.
You don't have to go be a monk.
I don't worry about this is so not necessarily make it.
Have you had an experience in the isolation tank?
I have not.
I really want to do that though.
I am consistently amazed at how many amazing,
interesting people haven't tried that out.
Yeah.
I just,
I haven't.
Where do you do it?
I can get you in.
You want to try it as a place in while there's a,
the best place in the world actually is in Venice.
Yeah.
Venice A,
I dunno if that's close to you,
but it's a one in Burbank.
There's a place called soothing solutions in Burbank,
but the issue of the Burbank place as opposed to the Venice place though is the
tanks.
Burbank place is fine.
I mean if you're close to that,
definitely go in.
The lady who runs it is super cool.
The difference is what that guy at the float lab has done.
The float lab is the place in Venice.
He's ticking floating to a completely different place.
He's a super genius,
this guys and nuts and he creates these unbelievably solid,
amazing,
huge tanks that are so regulated and the,
they pump oxygen into them.
He's got it down to such a science that when you're in that,
I mean it's,
it's just so the environment is so perfect,
completely soundproof.
You don't feel anything.
You're floating through space.
Your body is just like the water's the same temperature as your skin.
So as you float there,
you literally don't feel the water you're released of massive amounts of
tension.
Physical.
Alright.
It's amazingly recharging just physically.
And then if you go in there with brownies,
you get to meet aliens.
I believe that.
Absolutely.
Because all you have to do is just get past that your belief that this is what's
in front of me.
So I can't possibly see aliens.
But if you remove all that,
absolutely.
And we say aliens just as,
yeah,
the spiritual diligence.
Yeah.
Being silly.
It should be something that talks back.
Yeah.
That's what I like to talk to.
That's when you realize that because some people think,
oh,
the way that I believe is very lonely.
Yeah.
No,
no,
you don't put you up to the holidays.
We are anything but alone.
Yeah.
It makes me
very thankful whenever I come out of there.
That's probably been like the biggest tool for developing my own personality.
My own view of reality is that because it's a real reset,
it's a real time off when everything is shut off.
And when I get out I just want to call my friends and tell them I love them.
I just want to pet my dog or just want to,
I really like thankful.
How long do you stay in it?
A couple hours.
I like to do two hours.
I just think it's,
um,
it's,
it's another thing that I would like to see spread and I know some people are
doing it.
My friend Scotty from a on the mat.com he's got a,
a tank center that he's looking into opening and California and then uh,
uh,
earn La Rather.
And then I know the float labs going to open up another place in Hollywood too,
so there's,
and there's plenty of business out there if more people did it.
A lot of people want to know about this and a lot of people would benefit
massively.
Like if you enjoy getting a massage every now and then you enjoy taking a yoga
class.
This is that times a hundred cool.
We're really inquire will do that.
Thank you.
You should totally do that.
Yeah.
What's wrong with your music that you come up with some crazy shit from in
there?
Too much space.
Wow.
Yeah.
Just being complete floating around in there and do it.
How do you write?
Do you,
do you sit down with a guitar or do you sit down with a piece of paper?
Do you bowl?
Well,
it always starts with inspiration,
so that can be different.
That can be me sitting here going,
oh,
wait a minute.
Maybe you just said something that sounds rhythmic,
that sounds like,
oh,
I want to write about,
do you just go run out of the room and write it down?
Actually,
I use the iPhone a lot to just make notes to myself or if I hear a rhythm or a
sing,
a melody or something,
I'll put it on the voice memo.
Yeah,
I do that a lot.
And then when I have time,
when I make time,
I tried to make,
you know,
two,
three,
four hours and I can sit down and really just work something out.
So you know what's going out.
Amazing.
I don't know if you've ever used it on the iPhone.
It has this little um,
icon.
Apparently the android phones have this now as well.
For the,
for the notes,
if you press it,
you press this little microphone icon next hit space bar and you can talk into
it and it does it in real time.
It's amazing.
Like check this out,
watch Melissa Etheridge is a bad mother.
Fuck.
Watch this.
Bam,
look at that.
I've got a quick that is,
oh it typed it out.
It typed it out perfectly when you said I have this.
So I,
cause I used to,
I have a lot of stuff that I wrote in my little note pad but I'm not as fast
with my thumbs is that is.
And sometimes like for me,
uh,
a new idea,
like a new idea for a joke is so slippery.
It's like a fish that I can't hold onto,
can't run.
And I got to write it down.
It's good.
Greg,
how's that go again?
Oh I got to,
someone's still talking to me like please stop,
stop talking for a second.
I gotta I gotta hold on.
What is this?
How do I write this down and then,
but if I could just say it,
it would be way better.
Like I could get the idea completely.
Cause sometimes my ideas are so ridiculous.
Like I have to go back and read them like two or three times to figure out even
what the Hell I was saying.
But these,
um,
these new little icon,
these new little,
um,
note features where you could do that with just the microphone.
It's amazing.
These new cell phones are just,
well,
you can do with them.
It's just unbelievable.
It's so crazy.
So you write things down just when you have this idea where you record like the
melody,
like you hum it or something like that into your voice memos.
Yeah.
It depends on,
or I'll play.
If it's a piece of guitar playing,
I'll play that or piano or whatever it is.
It always comes from different places and then I'll give the time to work it out
and do what if it's going to be,
I love when people still keep creating.
They just never stopped.
They just keep pumping stuff out.
I love it.
It's so,
it's so fun.
It's so fun to be a part of,
uh,
this crazy culture that,
you know,
w it was crazy world that we live in now and see all the stuff that's coming out
too.
It's like we have more access to great information,
great music,
great movies,
great everything.
It's like,
it's,
we have so much access to inspiration.
We have so much access to art.
It's an amazing time.
Yeah.
And to see people embracing the Internet and using the Internet as a method of
spreading all this stuff too.
It's just,
I think it's,
we just live in just very,
very rare times.
That's another thing to be really,
really happy for and really appreciate it above this time,
this strange,
strange time that we exist to do you write and create as just a matter of like
you,
I mean you're so successful now,
you just must do it as a desire.
Like whenever you feel like it,
not every day like this is my gig.
Like how do you treat it nowadays?
My life is so full and so,
so blessed that when it's time for me to create something,
it's like I'm thinking about a musical.
Like I would really love to,
you know,
have a musical,
but that that's a big,
huge undertaking.
So I just
give myself say,
okay,
these few weeks I'm going to get myself from Monday to Friday from 10 to two
every day.
That's what I'm going to work.
And then when I'm done with that,
then I'll give myself some time off and then I'll say,
okay,
I'll gather the pieces of the notes,
the stuff,
and then I'll make another album.
I'll give myself,
you know,
I'll,
I'll actually work,
I'll make a time every day to work.
And when you do that and you put together an album,
do say,
okay,
you know what,
let's take this bitch on the road.
See what's up.
Oh yeah.
That's the,
that's the best part.
And it's great to create out of nothing and make music is I'm,
I love it.
I would do it all the time for nothing.
And then when I get to take that and share it with a thousand,
2000 a night and,
and here,
here they are.
And they,
and they love that music and I'm singing it.
And in it's an energy exchange that then it's just beyond.
That's just wonderful.
Yeah.
The live energy exchange.
Isn't it amazing when the glue your fans and the Chemo there,
Melissa Etheridge fans and you know you hit him with one of the classics and you
see their eyes light up and starting the song that people know,
oh,
it must be an amazing feeling.
It's an amazing feeling to be an audience member in a song you love comes on
like that,
but to be able to do it,
that must be crazy.
You're a weird conduit.
Yes,
I am and it's what it,
what it really boils down to.
Absolutely.
You move the energy through you right out.
Yeah.
People that think that's hippy crazy,
like there's something happening.
Why am I getting goosebumps?
There must be something that actually somebody just sent me that the other day
that some sort of a scientific explanation for why music gives you goosebumps,
but I say that's horse shit.
You know what I'm saying?
Fuck.
That means why argument?
It gives me goosebumps and not you.
Why am I responding to it?
But to another person that's not the right music.
You know?
You don't believe.
That's what's really important to recognize that in a lot of people it takes
them a long time to figure this out is that everybody likes different stuff.
They just do and they are some people that are not going to be,
they're not tuned into it for whatever reason.
They're not I.
It's a weird thing when you are a performer and you and you are beholden to
people buying your records in that,
that chart position or that,
that certain position,
that number and you think,
oh my gosh,
I want everyone to like me and it's just not possible.
It's not Bob,
and that's a good thing everybody,
and that's why you can then it helps in my belief when I,
oh,
I,
I believe that those who resonate with the music I make will come to it and it
would just be fine.
Everybody else,
I'm not blaming you judging,
it's just that's what you are.
Yeah.
I mean there's billions of people.
The people that they'll only love you for who you are.
If you are who you are and if you tried to be a bunch of different people on a
bunch of different things,
we see that over and over.
We see these people just lose it because they have created a certain persona in
the public eye and then they feel,
you start feeling like that persona,
Eh,
that's not you.
So any accolades that that persona gets is not you.
And then you're just miserable.
He started drinking and you're fucking crazy puzzles.
You're driving fast and they're taking your picture.
How do you avoid it?
Like crazy rock star cliches like that?
Well,
I figured I uh,
I have two ex wives,
you know,
two baby mamma's side.
I figure I fall into the rock and roll to Exelon.
I know what is,
I like to stay in contact.
I have to have two children with each of them while I know and I have to send
them.
That's hilarious.
It's the same cliche appears in the male,
female,
male,
female world.
You got to pay for it no matter what.
That's what they say.
Nobody rides for free.
Right.
Oh,
so you know,
what would I do?
We actually,
because when it comes to the kids,
we get along.
Okay.
You know,
there's,
I,
I don't have to socialize with them and that's fine.
But for the kids,
they need a,
uh,
a happy,
not happy,
but they need a,
a cohesive unit that they go back and forth from.
And so I,
I'm determined to do that.
That's awesome.
Um,
the,
the lesbian relationship dynamic,
is it often like the male female heterosexual dynamic or it depends on who you
are.
It depends on what you,
Paul's with his to Melissa averages both bad asses and that together.
Is that,
that'd be nice.
Yeah.
Right.
I have,
um,
my partner now,
her name is Linda and she is a television producer,
writer,
director.
She did nurse Jackie.
So she's successful.
Yes.
I know this bad ass is living together.
Exactly.
And that it actually,
because I believe,
because I finally started believing in myself a few years ago.
Okay,
I'm a bad ass.
Then I'm going to draw it.
But that's what you got to do.
Then you got to draw,
then you will draw a bad ass to you because you are vibrating that that's the
only way.
If you're sitting there going,
I need someone to fix me,
I need someone to come and be,
then you're going to think yourself as broken and broken.
People will come to you.
Yeah.
This is something that is driving scientists crazy right now.
They're hearing this and they're going this demo,
Melissa Etheridge mirrors nonsense.
What are you saying?
Show me the studies.
Show me peer reviewed papers are shut it.
Yeah.
Uh,
I think there's a lot of merit to what you're saying.
I don't know if it's right,
but I do believe that believing in it,
it's very powerful and I think that's all I say.
You're obviously living embodiment of that,
you know,
and also a person who's experienced the ups and downs of not being aware of the
body and then re changing it and becoming aware,
becoming much happier.
And you know,
and I do not do it perfect every day.
Again,
this is a practice I make,
my choices.
I live,
I go up and down.
But that's life.
Especially when you're busy.
It's hard.
It's hard to manage it all and keep cool and treat everybody as if it's you
living another life.
Yes,
it is difficult,
isn't it?
Well listen,
you just,
you being on here,
it was a huge treat.
It was a an honor and it was a,
it was weird,
you know,
because it was like I kept telling me what to do,
but most of us are just coming on here.
I tell him
he does to Brian and I,
we started doing this in my living room on a laptop as a goof.
But you believe you loved it.
What was it you love will grow?
Well,
it became something somewhere along the line.
I don't know how it happened,
but it just did and we're just sort of riding it,
you know?
I figured you would ask me the questions that I want to be asked.
I'm always available to talk like this,
but no one has stuff.
And then they will,
they'll ask me the same 10 questions over there.
Well,
it's very obvious that this way of thinking is important to you,
to,
you want to express it.
And you,
you're very courageous and expressing it because it sounds fucking crazy.
Well,
people,
what have I got to lose?
And I'm not saying it sounds crazy to me all it does sound crazy to me.
It also sounds possible to me,
you know,
I think there's a,
there's a lot of weirdness to the way we perceive the world and there's a lot of
strange,
if you can even start from that is maybe that,
which I think is so definite is not.
If you can start from that,
then you're on a journey.
I think having these conversations are very,
very important.
I think having these conversations publicly and just the consideration that
takes to not necessarily accept the idea,
but just to consider the points of it and not,
as I said,
I believe that that is possible,
but I also believe in asteroids.
I believe that if you're in the wrong place at tiger will eat your ass and it
doesn't mean you're a bad person.
You live in India,
London bed.
Yeah,
exactly.
So a beautiful way of looking at the world,
and again,
you might be right.
There's a lot of,
there's a lot of flexibility to this thing that we exist in and it doesn't seem
like we are operating on a long history of people's work where they've really
figured it out.
It seems like as a culture,
we've been doing crazy barbaric shift to each other since the jump and we're now
just in this period of abundance starting to go,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
Let's Google that.
You know,
is that true?
Are you sure that's true?
What are we doing here exactly?
Where's the,
where's the oil?
Whose,
whose gun is that a real UFO?
What the fuck is big?
But that's all happening right now and thank you very much more so it was big,
beautiful talking to you.
It was a real pleasure and an honor.
Thank you very much.
Thank you so much.
Your new CD.
I have it here it is.
Um,
some of this in it.
I do put that in my music too,
you know?
Yeah.
It's a fourth street feeling.
And is it out everywhere?
Amazon and iTunes.
Yeah.
It's unlike a lot of CCS.
There's a lot of artwork put into the actual cover,
which I really miss.
I mean,
I'm not old enough to really remember too many records,
but when I was a little kid,
I had a Cheech and Chong record and it was big bamboo and I opened it up and it
was like,
I didn't even know what smoking pot was back then.
I was,
you know,
I was like eight but I'm are probably knew what it was,
but I wasn't into it.
But you know,
it's not why I bought it because it was funny.
But there,
their album cover was this big like rolling paper thing and you would open it up
and it was like,
there was so much work put into it,
you know,
really an art form that I do miss.
Yeah.
This the deluxe version,
my record companies,
great.
They'll put out the regular version,
which has the,
I think there's 11 songs on there,
12 minutes and this is the deluxe version that I have a lot of fans that really
appreciate the extra artwork and the extra songs and so we put that on it.
That's great.
Photography.
Whoever it said that they,
they really sort of captured the tone of a lot of the music on here.
It's really awesome.
What does it,
what does that car is a replica.
It is a 64 Chevy impala.
I asked them to give because that's the first car I had when I was a kid.
That was the first car I ever bought when I was 15 I got it.
Wow.
Yeah.
So yeah.
So I said with a big bench seats in the back and the front was awesome.
It's amazing that people drove those with no seat belts.
No seatbelt.
Well,
you could,
I don't know how we survived without good.
We survive with,
we didn't have baby seats.
No,
nobody had figured that out.
We had no helmets.
No,
we had no seat belts.
Yeah.
Would you fall down?
You got fucked up was a kid
and everybody's parents smoked with the windows open.
I remember just sitting there and a cloud of smoke.
Yeah.
Strange Times.
All right.
Go.
Go get it.
You freaks fourth street feeling.
Melissa.
Thank you very much.
Thank you so much Joe.
Appreciate it.
This is awesome.
There's a lot of fun
and uh,
don't think that if Melissa talks to you on Twitter,
that's really Melissa.
All right.
Now you know it's a team,
Melissa,
unless she says it right.
All right,
you fox.
Thank you very much for tuning in.
Thank you to tank.
Go to Rogan Dot [inaudible] Dot Com and save 25 bucks off service or phone.
They have some awesome android phones and they have a,
a very ethical business model and we appreciate them being our sponsor.
Thanks also to [inaudible] dot com that's o,
n n I t,
makers of Alpha Brain shroom tech sport,
the fantastic nutritional supplement for endurance and all sorts of other groovy
shit like hemp fourth protein powder.
Go get some freaks.
Use a code name,
Rogan,
and save yourself 10% off any and all supplements.
All right.
We will see you tomorrow with a great Ari should fear,
well,
he would talk about his hate for the TSA and the great story of what happened
this weekend,
and I really wish I filmed it because it's going to be shut up is I couldn't
film it because I think you'd go to jail for doing that or something.
Patriotic Type Shit.
All right,
folks,
we'll see you tomorrow.
We love,
we love you always,
even though you are an illusion
created in my own mind.
No good.
No.
I'm an illusion
that you've created in your mind or both,
but it's awesome.
All right.
See you soon.
Love you.